This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. It happens all the time. The lovely couple with a nice house, beautiful family, and gainful careers unexpectedly find themselves drowning in tens of thousands of dollars of credit card debt. Debt grew by $93 billion at the end of 2024, and half of that increase came from new credit card debt. Or maybe it's the fresh college graduate, who rather than looking forward to a bright future and a sense of freedom, finds himself trying to pay back a series
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这种情况时常发生。那对拥有漂亮房子、美满家庭和稳定工作的可爱夫妇，突然发现自己陷入了数万美元的信用卡债务中无法自拔。2024年底，债务增加了930亿美元，其中一半的增幅来自新增的信用卡债务。或者换作刚毕业的大学生，他本该期待着光明的未来和自由感，却发现自己正在努力偿还一连串
of compounding loans, only to watch the balance grow year after year after year. One out of every four Americans with student loans is delinquent. That's nearly triple the pre-pandemic delinquency rate scene. And then there's the retiree who thought she had enough saved until one medical emergency wiped out her nest egg. And so you just start chipping away at your saving. shipping away at everything you have, and ultimately chipping away at retirement. It's easy to believe this would never happen to me. I would be smarter, savier, better at saving.
不断滚雪球般的贷款，眼睁睁看着余额年复一年地增长。每四个背负学生贷款的美国人中就有一人违约。这几乎是疫情前违约率的三倍。还有那位退休老人，她原本以为自己存够了钱，直到一场医疗紧急情况花光了她所有的积蓄。于是你开始一点点消耗积蓄，蚕食你拥有的每一样东西，最终侵蚀了你的退休生活。人们很容易认为这种事绝不会发生在我身上。我会更聪明、更精明、更善于存钱。
And yet, hundreds of millions of people around the world find themselves enmeshed in debt. Some of this has to do with reckless spending, of course. But even when you do everything right, budget, plan, and make reasonable choices, debt has a way of surprising you. Today on the show, the unseen traps that influence our behavior when it comes to money, the entities that take advantage of our mistakes, and how to win back our freedom. The Psychology of Debt, this week on Hidden Brain.
然而，全世界数以亿计的人发现自己陷入了债务的泥潭。当然，这其中有些是因为过度消费。但即便你把所有事情都做对了——制定预算、规划、做出理性的选择，债务也总有办法给你带来惊喜。今天的节目将探讨：当我们面对金钱时，那些影响我们行为的看不见的陷阱；利用我们的错误牟利的实体；以及如何重新赢回我们的自由。“债务心理学”，本周《隐藏的大脑》。
We like to think we are good with money. Make a budget, save a little bit each week, open a retirement account. With a little willpower and discipline, we're going to be okay. At Wright State University, John Dinsmore studies financial decision-making, how our minds work when it comes to money, and why our hopeful plans often fail to come to fruition. John Dinsmore, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me.
我们总喜欢认为自己很擅长理财。做个预算，每周存一点钱，开一个退休账户。只要有一点点毅力和纪律，我们就会过得很好。在莱特州立大学，约翰·丁斯莫尔研究的是财务决策——当涉及金钱时我们的思维如何运作，以及为什么我们充满希望的计划常常无法实现。约翰·丁斯莫尔，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢邀请我来。
John, I want to start with the story of businessman David Siegel and his wife, Jacqueline. Who were they, and how did they first come into money? Well, David Siegel was the timeshare king of the United States. So for those who aren't familiar, a timeshare is, let's say you want to have a vacation home in Florida, in Miami. Rather than having to buy an entire condo on your own, you would buy some portion of it and you would be assigned a certain number of weeks to be able to use at that timeshare location. But for a company like Westgate, which was David Siegel's company, it would also open you up to a larger timeshare network so that if you didn't want to go to Miami on vacation every year, you could maybe take weeks at some of their other properties, Las Vegas, San Diego, or wherever. And I understand that Jackie was a former Miss Florida pageant winner, and the two of them met in 1998, fell in love and had eight kids together. Yes, yes. So he had, David Siegel had been
约翰，我想从商人大卫·西格尔和他的妻子杰奎琳的故事开始讲起。他们是谁？他们又是如何最初发家致富的？嗯，大卫·西格尔是美国的“分时度假大王”。所以对于不太了解的人来说，分时度假的意思是，比方说你想在佛罗里达州的迈阿密拥有一套度假屋。与其自己买下一整套公寓，不如购买其中的一部分份额，这样你就会被分配到一定数量的weeks（周数），可以在那个分时度假地点使用。但对于像西门度假村（Westgate，大卫·西格尔的公司）这样的公司来说，它还会让你接入一个更大的分时度假网络，这样如果你不想每年都去迈阿密度假，你也许可以在他们的其他物业——拉斯维加斯、圣迭戈或其他任何地方——使用几周。据我所知，杰基曾是“佛罗里达小姐”选美比赛的冠军，两人于1998年相遇，坠入爱河并育有八个孩子。是的，是的。所以他，大卫·西格尔当时
very active with that particular beauty pageant and started to court Jackie. And yes, they had eight kids, which is a lot of kids. And so they were living together in what we would consider a very large house. It was like 26,000 square feet. So this 26,000 square foot home in Florida, it had 17 bathrooms, but apparently it wasn't really big enough because they started to imagine building and even bigger house. Yes. Well, they said they were just bursting at the seams, which is probably a, you know, they probably have a different standard than a lot of us. But bursting at the seams with 26,000 square feet, and I think they had gone on a vacation
非常积极地参与那个特定的选美比赛，并开始追求杰基。是的，他们有八个孩子，这确实有很多孩子。所以他们住在一个在我们看来非常大的房子里。大约有26,000平方英尺（约2400平方米）。所以这栋位于佛罗里达州的26,000平方英尺的豪宅有17间浴室，但显然它还不够大，因为他们开始构想建造一座更大的房子。是的。嗯，他们说他们已经是“人满为患、不堪重负”了，这可能是一个，你知道的，他们的标准可能和我们大多数人不同。虽然26,000平方英尺已经人满为患了，而且我想他们曾去法国
to France and seen the Palace of Versailles and decided, you know what, we're going to build a house just like the Palace of Versailles, and I think it was going to be like 90,000 square feet. I want to play you a clip of Jackie walking around the foundation of the house as it's being built. She and David are describing their plans for the home. This is from the documentary, the Queen of Versailles. And then he says, I want a health spot. And then I said, we need maids quarters. I forgot how many kitchens, 10 kitchens.
度假，参观了凡尔赛宫，然后决定，你知道吗，我们要建造一座一模一样的房子，就像凡尔赛宫那样，我想它大概有90,000平方英尺（约8300平方米）。我想放一段杰基在房子建设中的地基周围走动的音频剪辑。她和大卫正在描述他们对房子的规划。这出自纪录片《凡尔赛女王》。然后他说，我想要一个保健水疗中心。然后我说，我们需要女佣房。我忘了有多少个厨房，10个厨房。
We have a sushi bar. Two tennis courts. One will be a stadium court. Full-sized baseball field, which will double as the parking lot when we have parties. But this is our ice skating slash roller rink. So life is good. They're clearly living the American dream. What happens next, John?
我们有一个寿司吧。两个网球场。其中一个是体育场球场。标准大小的棒球场，开派对时可以用作停车场。但这块是我们的滑冰兼轮滑场。所以生活很美好。他们显然在过着美国梦。接下来发生了什么，约翰？
Well, the Great Recession starts. And with the Great Recession, well, Lehman Brothers Falls, and the banking industry is in crisis. And so no loans are going out. So David Siegel, with all of his properties, and in particular, a new property, what, P.H. Towers in Las Vegas.
嗯，大宗经济衰退开始了。随着大宗经济衰退的到来，雷曼兄弟倒闭了，银行体系陷入危机。所以没有任何贷款发出。因此，大卫·西格尔和他的所有房产，尤其是位于拉斯维加斯的新房产——P.H. Towers（棕榈大厦）。
Well, the bank stopped lending money, and so all of a sudden there was no money to be had anywhere. So they have to figure out not only what to do with David's business, but also with this gargantuan house that they were in the middle of trying to construct. I understand that before your academic career, John, you had a previous life in real estate, so you understand well the role that money plays in the real estate business. Yes. So for real estate developers, you know, it takes so long if you're building a shopping center or something like that. These projects are like, they like take 10 years to come to fruition. So I was actually out in Vegas when Ph. Towers was being built. And a project like that probably had started five years before that when the market was really good.
嗯，银行停止放贷了，所以突然之间到处都借不到钱。因此，他们不仅要想办法处理大卫的业务，还要处理这座他们正在建造中的庞大豪宅。据我所知，约翰，在你的学术生涯之前，你曾从事过房地产业，所以你很清楚金钱在房地产业务中扮演的角色。是的。对房地产开发商来说，你知道的，如果你在建造一个购物中心或类似的东西，这需要很长时间。这些项目大约需要10年才能实现。所以当时P.H. Towers正在建设时，我其实就在拉斯维加斯。像这样的项目可能在五年前市场状况极好的时候就已经开始了。
But we were, all of us out at this real estate conference in Las Vegas were looking at Ph. Towers. and another place that was called city center and just thinking, well, the market was already falling, how are these things going to survive? I mean, it was a very obvious crisis that was unfolding there. I want to play you another clip from the documentary. This is David Sahn,
但是我们，所有在拉斯维加斯参加这个房地产会议的人都在看着P.H. Towers以及另一个叫做CityCenter（城市中心）的地方，心里想的是，市场已经在下跌了，这些东西怎么能存活下来？我的意思是，那是一个显而易见的正在展开的危机。我想放一段来自这部纪录片的另一个剪辑。这是大卫·萨恩（David Sahn），
who was also a vice president of Westgate Resorts, describing the scenario. He will tell you that the lenders are pushers. They got us addicted, to cheap money. And once we were addicted, they took away our money. And now we're addicts.
他也是西门度假村的副总裁，他在描述当时的场景。他会告诉你，贷款机构就像是毒贩。他们让我们对廉价资金上瘾了。一旦我们上了瘾，他们就把我们的钱拿走了。现在我们成了瘾君子。
We have to have that money in order to maintain the company that we built. It's striking, John, the use of the words pushers and addicts. It is. I mean, I would argue that he's maybe rationalizing a little bit to deflect some blame. I mean, these are not unsophisticated people.
为了维持我们建立的公司，我们必须得到那些资金。约翰，使用“毒贩”和“瘾君子”这两个词真是令人印象深刻。确实如此。我的意思是，我认为他可能在某种程度上进行合理化解释，以推卸一些责任。我的意思是，这些人并非不够精明。
But he is right in the sense that when money is coming to you and it's affordable, the tendency is to think that it's always going to be that way. When, if you take a moment to think about it, you'll understand that, you know, things change. So the stock market is plummeting. It's, you know, once in a century financial crisis, it's called. What happens to this company and what happens to the Palace of Versailles, the new Palace of Versailles? Well, the company can't do anything if it's not getting money from banks, right? They've already put as much of their own money into it as they have, and then they need regular, they're called loan draws to keep the building going. And without the
但在某种意义上他是对的，当资金源源不断且成本低廉时，人们往往会认为情况会一直这样下去。然而，如果你花点时间思考一下，你就会明白，你知道的，事情是会变的。所以股市正在暴跌。这是一个，你知道的，被称为百年一遇的金融危机。这家公司发生了什么？凡尔赛宫——新的凡尔赛宫发生了什么？嗯，如果银行不给资金，公司什么也做不了，对吧？他们已经把自己能投的钱都投进去了，然后他们需要定期获得资金，这被称为贷款提款（loan draws）来维持工程继续。如果没有
loan draws, they can't do anything. So they have to lay off all of their people. And on a personal basis, the Siegel family is looking at this $100 million house that they're building. And they can't move forward on that either because they don't know, I mean, at some point, they tried to sell it while they were going through this cash crunch, but the difficulty is in a recession like that, nobody has any money. So, you know, they were trying to sell the biggest house in America at a time where no one's buying any houses, let alone, you know, a 90,000 square foot house. I'm wondering what you make of the story, John. In many ways, these people seem so completely out of touch with reality. They have maids and drivers and private planes, and it's hard to feel
这些贷款提款，他们什么也做不了。所以他们必须解雇所有的员工。就个人而言，西格尔一家面对着这栋价值1亿美元正在建造中的房子，他们也无法继续推进，因为他们不知道，我的意思是，在某个时刻，他们在经历这场现金紧缩时曾试图把它卖掉，但困难在于，在那样的大萧条中，没有人有钱。所以，你知道的，他们试图在没人买房的时候出售全美最大的房子，更不用说是一栋90,000平方英尺的房子了。我很想知道你对这个故事有何看法，约翰。在许多方面，这些人似乎与现实完全脱节。他们有女佣、司机和私人飞机，很难对他们
sorry for them, and yet there also seems to be something very human about their story. It is very human. I mean, they seem like nice people, right? Even though they're living this very extreme sort of lifestyle, in one point in the documentary, a friend of Jackie's, I think, is having trouble making her house payments. And so Jackie sends her, I want to say, $5,000 to hopefully save the house. they had had a good run of success, however much luck was involved. Things had been working well for a while.
感到同情，然而他们的故事中似乎又有一些非常有人情味的东西。确实非常有人情味。我的意思是，他们看起来像是好人，对吧？尽管他们过着这种非常极端的的生活方式，但在纪录片的一个片段中，杰基的一个朋友似乎在支付房贷时遇到了困难。于是杰基寄给她，我想大概是50,000美元，希望能帮她保住房子。他们曾有过一段成功的经历，无论其中包含多少运气。事情曾有一段时间进展得很顺利。
And then they just got in over their skis a little bit and didn't think that things would turn against them. And all of a sudden they had to start making some pretty tough choices as far as things to give up and how to keep their house and all those things. So where do things stand right now with? this grand house, John. Is it still under construction? What's happened to it? It is still under construction. They had paused construction during the financial crisis because they didn't have any money. They had tried to sell the partially constructed house at one
然后他们有点得意忘形，没想到局势会逆转对他们不利。突然之间，他们不得不做出一些非常艰难的选择，比如要放弃什么，以及如何保住房子等等。那么约翰，这座宏伟的豪宅现在情况如何？它还在建设中吗？发生了什么？它仍在建设中。他们在金融危机期间暂停了建设，因为他们没有钱。他们曾试图把这座建设到一半的房子出售，
point, but no one was buying. But after a few years and once Westgate Resorts was able to move forward and become financially solvent, they began construction again. But Jackie, just posted on social media this year, that it is still not finished. The story of David and Jackie may seem extreme, but it illustrates many of the psychological traps that affect us all. More on how these traps work and how to avoid them when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. John Dinsmore studies financial decision-making at Wright State University.
但没有人买。但在几年后，一旦西门度假村得以向前发展并恢复财务偿付能力，他们就重新开始了建设。不过，杰基今年刚在社交媒体上发文称，它仍然没有完工。大卫和杰基的故事看起来可能很极端，但它说明了许多影响我们所有人的心理陷阱。稍后我们将为您带来更多关于这些陷阱如何运作以及如何避开它们的讨论。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。约翰·丁斯莫尔在莱特州立大学研究财务决策。
He's also a fan of the hit television show, The Office, where Steve Carell plays Michael Scott, an office manager at a paper supply company whose dreams are much bigger than his reality. In one episode, Michael visits a high school. He's meeting a group of graduating high school seniors, whom he first met 10 years earlier when the students were third graders. During that earlier meeting, Michael promised to pay the entire class's way through college. John, you've seen this episode many times and say that it's based on a real life story. Yes.
他也是热门电视剧《办公室》的粉丝，剧中史蒂夫·卡瑞尔饰演迈克尔·斯科特，他是纸品供应公司的一名办公室经理，梦想远比现实宏大。在其中一集里，迈克尔访问了一所高中。他与一群即将毕业的高中生见面，他第一次见到这群学生是在10年前，当时他们还是三年级小学生。在那次早些时候的会面中迈克尔承诺资助全班同学上大学。约翰，你已经看过这一集很多次了，并说它是基于真实生活的故事。是的。
There was a man named Eugene Lang, who was a wealthy investor in New York City. And so he had visited an elementary school in Harlem, where he promised those six-graders, I guess, that he would pay their way through college. And he had significant resources. He not only followed through on the promise, he put another 16,000 kids through college. Wow. Was the same true for Michael Scott in the fictional TV series? The same was not true. Michael Scott wanted to be a hero to these kids, but he had no such resources. But he thought that he would one day. But unfortunately, it didn't work out quite that way. I want to play a clip from that episode. It's both funny and sad.
有一个名叫尤金·朗（Eugene Lang）的人，他是纽约市的一位富有投资者。他曾访问哈莱姆区的一所小学，向那些大概六年级的学生承诺，他会资助他们上大学。他拥有可观的资源。他不仅兑现了诺言，还资助了另外16,000名孩子上大学。哇。虚构电视剧中的迈克尔·斯科特也是如此吗？事实并非如此。迈克尔·斯科特想成为这些孩子心目中的英雄，但他没有这样的资源。但他以为自己总有一天会有。但不幸的是，事情并没有完全按照那样发展。我想播放那一集的一个片段。既搞笑又悲伤。
You lied to us. I lied to myself, too. I'm not a millionaire. I thought I would be. by the time I was 30, but I wasn't even close. And then I thought maybe by the time I was 40, but by 40 I had less money than when I was 30. Maybe by my 50s. I don't know. John, you say the story is a classic example of optimism bias?
你对我们撒了谎。我也对自己撒了谎。我不是百万富翁。我以为我到30岁的时候会是的，但我连边都没沾到。然后我想也许到40岁的时候会是，但到了40岁时，我的钱比30岁时还要少。也许到50多岁吧。我不知道。约翰，你说这个故事是乐观偏见的经典例子？
Absolutely. I mean, we all tend to think that our ship's going to come in, that we're going to get our big break or we're going to get the promotion. We don't really ever think about that, you know, life is full of surprises, both good and bad. So, you know, we never think that, you know, maybe we'll get laid off from a job where about half of workers get laid off at one point or another, or we don't think we're going to get passed over for that promotion. But these things happen. But when we think about the future, we never really incorporate those potential negative surprises into our vision of the future. You once saw a documentary about D-Day, which gave you another interesting example of the optimism.
绝对是的。我的意思是，我们都倾向于认为我们的好运就要来了，我们要走大运了，或者我们要升职了。我们其实从不考虑，你知道的，生活充满惊喜，有好的也有坏的。所以，你知道的，我们从不认为，也许我们会从一份有一半员工迟早会被裁掉的工作中被解雇，或者我们不会认为我们会与晋升失之交臂。但这些事情确实会发生。然而当我们考虑未来时，我们从未真正将这些潜在的负面惊喜纳入我们对未来的设想中。你曾看过一部关于诺曼底登陆的纪录片，这给你提供了关于乐观的另一个有趣例子。
buyers. Can you tell me that story? Okay, so the documentary was going through the events of D-Day, and then they would flash forward talking to some veterans decades later, recalling their experiences. And there was a man who stormed the beach at Omaha, and he recalled getting briefed on the mission ahead, and the commanding officer said, look, two out of three of you are not going to make it through this. And he was 18 years old, and he was 18 years old, and he was looked to the man on either side of him and thought, well, these poor bastards. He never thought that he was ever actually in danger. He thought that, well, the people next to me have a hundred percent chance of not making it through, but I'm going to be fine. And that's very optimistic.
买家。你能跟我讲讲那个故事吗？好的，所以那部纪录片回顾了诺曼底登陆的事件，然后镜头快进到几十年后采访一些老兵，让他们回忆自己的经历。当时有一个人在奥马哈海滩冲锋，他回忆起听取关于前方任务的简报时，指挥官说，听着，你们中有三分之二的人无法活着离开这里。他当时18岁，他当时18岁，他看着自己左右两边的人心想，嗯，这些可怜的家伙。他从不认为自己其实处于危险之中。他心想，好吧，我旁边的人活下来的概率是零，但我会没事的。这非常乐观。
And the younger we are, the more optimistic we tend to be. Talk about this. There's research that shows that younger people tend to have more of the optimism bias than older people. Yes, so the younger you are, the more optimistic you tend to be. The more you think things are going to fall into your favor. And so this is, it's a great thing for perseverance. Optimism is it's not always great for dealing with finances. It tends to have us bite off more than we can chew. I'm thinking about all the choices that young people have to make.
而且我们越年轻，往往就越乐观。谈谈这个。有研究表明，年轻人比老年人往往具有更多的乐观偏见。是的，所以你越年轻，往往就越乐观。你越觉得事情会朝着对你有利的方向发展。所以这是一个极其有利于坚持不懈的特质。但乐观并不总是有利于处理财务问题。它往往会让我们“咬下比自己能咀嚼的更多的东西”（贪多嚼不烂）。我想到了年轻人必须做出的大量选择。
When you're in your late teens or early 20s, you might be deciding to go to college, you might be deciding to take on student loans, you might be a young person just starting out in your first job. And if you actually believe that things are going to be rosier than they actually are, you could be in for a surprise. Absolutely. It's at a time where a lot of people, you know, when you're 18, you're thinking about going to college, you're considering student loans.
当你处于十几岁后期或二十出头时，你可能在决定上大学，你可能在决定背负学生贷款，你可能是一个刚刚开始第一份工作的年轻人。如果你真的相信事情会比实际情况更加美好，你可能会大吃一惊。绝对是的。正是在许多人面临抉择的时期，你知道的，当你18岁时，你在考虑上大学，你在考虑学生贷款。
And this is at a time where, I mean, if you're like me, you're not really, sure what you want to do. And if you pick a major, you don't know if you'll enjoy it, you'll be good at it, or you'll even work in it. And yet you are having to take out debt to finance this education for something where you may or may not be making enough money to justify the investment. Hmm. I want you to tell me a personal story. I understand that in the fall of 2005, life was coming at you pretty fast. You had just been offered a job in Richmond, Virginia, You'd also met the woman of your dreams in Washington, D.C.
正是在这个时候，我的意思是，如果你像我一样，你其实并不确定自己想做什么。如果你选了一个专业，你不知道自己是否会喜欢它、是否能学好它，甚至以后会不会从事这个行业。然而你却不得不背负债务来资助这项教育，而这笔教育投资未来是否能赚到足够的钱来回本，还是个未知数。嗯。我想让你给我讲一个个人的故事。据我了解，在2005年秋天，生活向你扑面而来的速度非常快。你刚刚在弗吉尼亚州里士满获得了一份工作，你还在华盛顿特区遇到了你梦寐以求的女性。
Tell me about your life at that time, John. It was a really exciting time. I was working for a real estate development company, and I had met Alyssa up at Glover Park in D.C. There was a dog park there, and we were both walking our dogs. And we started dating in November, and it was a bit of a whirlwind romance, and the real estate company wanted to move me down.
约翰，跟我们讲讲你当时的生活吧。那是一段非常激动人心的时光。我在一家房地产开发公司工作，我在华盛顿特区的格洛弗公园（Glover Park）遇到了阿丽莎（Alyssa）。那里有一个狗公园，我们当时都在遛狗。我们在11月开始约会，那是一场旋风般的浪漫，而且房地产公司想把我调动到
to Richmond, Virginia from D.C., and I just, we were on the same page of where things were going between me and Alyssa. So I just assumed she would come and she was fine with it, but she said, you know, I'm not moving to Richmond with my boyfriend, wink, wink. So, which was fine. We were, you know, we were both on the same page on that. So we were, we went down to Richmond to look for our house and separately I was looking for a ring. So you were hoping to close in a house and then proposed to Alyssa. You knew a friend of a friend who was a mortgage broker who was going to help you through this transition. Yeah, it was actually one of the owners of the real estate company that I worked for.
弗吉尼亚州的里士满，离开华盛顿特区，我只是，我和阿丽莎对未来的发展有着完全一致的看法。所以我理所当然地以为她会跟我一起去，她对此也并不介意，但她说，你知道的，我不会带着“男朋友”的身份搬去里士满的，眨眼，眨眼。所以，这也没问题。我们当时，你知道的，在这方面意见完全一致。所以我们去了里士满看房，与此同时我单独在物色一枚戒指。所以你当时希望敲定一套房子，然后向阿丽莎求婚。你认识一个朋友的朋友是房贷经纪人，他将帮助你度过这段过渡期。是的，实际上是我工作的房地产公司的老板之一。
He recommended a friend to me. So we started going through the process of getting approved for a mortgage and he said there shouldn't be any problems. You were also buying a ring. Were you planning to pay cash for the ring? John? No. We were, I was going to put the ring on credit, but wanted to wait until the house was bought, so as to not have anything extra on my credit report when we were doing the underwriting for the house.
他向我推荐了一个朋友。于是我们开始着手申请房贷的流程，他说应该不会有什么问题。你当时也在买戒指。你当时打算用现金买戒指吗，约翰？没有。我们，我打算用信用卡买戒指，但想等到买下房子之后再买，这样在为房子做承销时，我的信用报告上就不会有任何额外的负债。
All right. So there's a lot going on. You're getting engaged. You're moving to a new city. You're trying to buy a house. You're trying to buy a ring. Tell me what happened next. We were about two or three.
好吧。所以有很多事情正在发生。你要订婚了。你要搬到一个新城市。你正试图买房。你正试图买戒指。告诉我接下来发生了什么。我们大概在买房前的两三天，
days before closing the house. And then the mortgage broker calls up and said, well, there's a problem. And the mortgage that I told you would be able to get, we can't get. So you're going to need to do something called a no-doc mortgage. And a no-doc mortgage, this is in the height of the housing craze in the housing bubble. It was a mortgage you could get without providing any proof of income. And in exchange for not providing proof of income, you were going to pay a higher interest rate and higher fees. Well, you must have been taken aback at this point because it felt like the rug was being pulled out from under you. Yes, I didn't necessarily suspect anything right away. It was more just, okay, well, you know, I don't want to be homeless. And we were supposed
房贷经纪人打电话来说，嗯，出问题了。我之前告诉你能够办下来的房贷，现在办不成了。所以你需要做一种叫做“无文件房贷”（no-doc mortgage）的东西。而无文件房贷——这正值房地产热潮和房地产泡沫的顶峰——是一种无需提供任何收入证明就能获得的房贷。作为不提供收入证明的交换，你需要支付更高的利率和更高的费用。好吧，你当时一定大吃一惊，因为这感觉就像是有人抽掉了你脚下的地毯。是的，我并没有立刻起疑心。更多的感觉只是，好吧，你知道的，我可不想无家可归。我们本该在几天内
to have this house in a couple of days, but felt really stuck. We actually didn't feel. like we necessarily had any other option. So there were a couple of moments when you realized that something was off. First you had your dad look at the paperwork? Yeah, my dad was a real estate attorney in Virginia Beach and so he offered to do the closing and when we were going through the closing he noticed first he noticed the prepayment penalty and he said well these are illegal in Virginia so you should talk to your underwriter to have it removed moved. But we went ahead because we wanted to close the house. And I can't remember if I ever
买下这栋房子，但当时确实感到进退维谷。我们实际上并不觉得我们还有别的选择。所以有那么几个时刻，你意识到有些不对劲。首先是你让你父亲看了文件？是的，我父亲是弗吉尼亚海滩的房地产律师，所以他主动提出帮我们办理过户交割，当我们在审核过户文件时，他首先注意到了预付款罚金（prepayment penalty），他说，嗯，这些在弗吉尼亚州是非法的，所以你应该和你的贷款承销商谈谈，把它去掉。但我们还是继续推进了，因为我们想把房子买下来。我不记得我是否曾
talked to the underwriter about the prepayment penalty, but we would refinance some years later. And then we got this mystery check for $3,000 after the refinance, which was refunding the illegal prepayment penalty. So the people you were working with don't seem like particularly nice people, John. You could say that. I mean, working in real estate developments, a lot of times you are swimming with sharks, and it felt at times that I was swimming with sharks. Now, the other owner of the company, when he had asked me about how the closing went, and I told him, he got just kind of an annoyed look on his face. I think he immediately smelled a rat and said, you know, next time, let me put you in touch with someone. And that was the first time where I really thought, okay, this was maybe deliberate. So the fact that you ended up not getting the mortgage you thought you were going to get, that you had this last minute switch. How much did it end up costing you over the long run, John? Let's see, we had that mortgage for probably about two years. And the original, like more normal mortgage was going to be about $2,100 a month. And the no-doc mortgage took us to, I think, $3,300. And so you do the math a couple of years. It cost us about $30,000. Wow. You talk about a principle known as intertemporal discounting,
和承销商谈过预付款罚金的事，但几年后我们进行了再融资。然后我们在再融资后收到了这张3000美元的神秘支票，退还了非法的预付款罚金。所以你合作的那些人似乎并不是特别好的人，约翰。你可以这么说。我的意思是，在房地产开发行业工作，很多时候你是在与鲨鱼共泳，而我有时确实觉得自己是在与鲨鱼共泳。现在，公司的另一位老板，当他问我过户进展得怎么样，而我把情况告诉他时，他的脸上露出了一种烦恼的表情。我想他立刻嗅到了猫腻，并说，你知道的，下次让我给你介绍个人。那是第一次我真正心想，好吧，这或许是故意的。所以，你最终没有拿到你以为能拿到的房贷，而且在最后一刻被调包了。从长远来看，这到底花掉了你多少钱，约翰？让我想想，我们背负那个房贷大概两年左右。原本比较正常的房贷每月大约是2100美元。而无文件房贷让我们涨到了，我想是3300美元。所以你算算两年的数学账。它让我们多花了大约3万美元。哇。你谈到一个被称为“跨期贴现”（intertemporal discounting）的原则，
and it's all about how, in some ways, we imagine that the future is going to be more flush than the present. And this is true when it comes to time. It's also true when it comes to money. Yeah, absolutely. So if you take the instance of this no-doc mortgage that I found myself in the middle of, there were a lot of components to it where you look at it, and there are fees there that are just getting rolled into the loan.
它主要讲的是，在某种程度上，我们想象未来会比现在更加富裕。这在时间上是这样的。在金钱上也是如此。是的，绝对是这样。所以如果你以我身处其中的这个无文件房贷为例，它有很多组成部分，当你审视它时，里面有些费用直接被滚入（rolled into）了贷款中。
And when something gets rolled into a loan, whether it's, you know, a mortgage or a car loan or something like that, because it is pushed off into the future and it's bundled with all these other fees, we tend to not really understand how much we're paying for it and how much it's actually costing us. So in other words, if someone were to tell you, you know, you have to pay 500 bucks more today, you might say, well, I don't have 500 bucks. but if someone says you have to pay 500 bucks two years from now, you imagine that your future self is somehow going to be able to come up with that money. Absolutely. Well, and it's often the future too, and so it doesn't really seem like $500. As silly as that sounds. I'm wondering how this speaks to the growing interest in, you know, buy now, pay later schemes.
当某笔费用被滚入贷款时——无论是房贷、车贷还是类似的东西——因为它被推迟到了未来，并且与所有这些其他费用捆绑在一起，我们往往无法真正理解我们为此付出了多少，以及它实际上让我们付出了多大代价。换句话说，如果有人对你说，你知道的，你今天必须多付500块钱，你可能会说，嗯，我没有500块钱。但如果有人说你两年后必须付500块钱，你就会想象未来的自己不知怎么地能够搞到这笔钱。绝对是的。嗯，而且那往往是在未来，所以它看起来并不真的像是500美元。听起来虽傻，但事实确实如此。我想知道这说明了现在人们对“先买后付”（buy now, pay later）计划日益增长的兴趣。
These are not just credit schemes. It are just schemes that basically defer payments into the future. And there are a whole number of marketers and companies that are sprouted up that allow us to buy, you know, seemingly extravagant things today with the promise that we don't have to pay for them today. Right. By now, pay later is, it continues to surge in popularity. And it's really just a reframing of credit cards. But one of the funny things about how inconsistent we are in assessing the cost of debt is that, okay, we're not going to call it credit card. We're not going to call it a loan.
这些不仅仅是信贷计划。这些只是基本上将支付推迟到未来的计划。涌现出了大批营销人员和公司，它们允许我们今天购买，你知道的，看似奢侈的东西，并承诺我们今天不必为此付款。没错。“先买后付”的流行度持续飙升。它其实只是信用卡的一种重新包装。但关于我们在评估债务成本时表现得多么不一致，其中一个有趣的事情是，好吧，我们不叫它信用卡。我们不叫它贷款。
We'll just call it buy now, pay later. And that sounds very. friendly, even though it's the same thing. And if you look at the interest rates on some of these things, they are as high or higher than an expensive credit card. But because we see it, oh, well, this isn't a credit card. This is, I'm just getting it now and then I'll deal with it later. It shouldn't sway our decision making, but it does. You know, I was reading a New York Times article a few weeks ago, John, and it was about a buy now pay later company called Klarna. And it used a term that I had not heard before called Clarna Maxing. Have you heard this term before?
我们只管它叫“先买后付”。这听起来非常友好，尽管它其实是同一回事。如果你看一下其中一些方案的利率，它们和昂贵的信用卡一样高，甚至更高。但因为我们看到的是，哦，好吧，这不是信用卡。这是，我只是现在拿到它，以后再处理它。这本不该动摇我们的决策，但它确实动摇了。你知道的，几个星期前我在读《纽约时报》的一篇文章，约翰，内容是关于一家名为Klarna的“先买后付”公司的。它使用了一个我以前没听过的术语，叫做“Klarna Maxing”（疯狂使用Klarna/Klarna最大化）。你以前听说过这个词吗？
I have not heard Clarna Maxing. I mean, I think if we go back to like the No Doc loans, of course, it's an absurd notion that will lend you $300,000 to buy a house without, you know, verifying your income. And that will work for a while. But when the economy turns and economies go through cycles, that's when a lot of these things come crashing down. Now, I don't know Clarnas specific in terms of how they deal with this. But if you look at the mortgage industry, their thing was we'll be selling these liabilities off to other people.
我没听说过“Klarna Maxing”。我的意思是，如果我们回过头来看看无文件贷款，当然，借给你30万美元买房而不验证你的收入，这是一个荒谬的想法。这在一段时间内确实行得通。但当经济转向时，经济总是要经历周期的，正是那时许多这类东西才会轰然崩塌。现在，我不知道Klarna在处理这个问题上的具体做法。但如果你看看房贷行业，他们的做法是：我们会把这些债务卖给其他人。
So I'd be curious to see if they're holding those liabilities or not because once the economy goes in a downward turn, a lot of these people are going to stop making payments. When we come back, more mental traps that can lure us into debt. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
所以我很好奇他们究竟是在自己持有这些债务，还是没有持有，因为一旦经济下行，许多这样的人就会停止还款。稍后我们将继续探讨诱使我们陷入债务的更多心理陷阱。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. Have you had an experience in your life where you thought you were getting a great deal, only to find yourself mired in debt? Have you found ways to protect yourself from getting in over your head financially? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the hidden brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the audio file to us using the email address,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。你是否有过这样的经历：你以为自己捡到了一个大便宜，结果却发现自己深陷债务泥潭？你有没有找到保护自己免于在财务上陷入困境的方法？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录下一段语音备忘录。两到三分钟就足够了。将音频文件发送到我们的邮箱：
feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, money. Again, that email address is feedback at hiddenbrain.org. John Dinsmore studies financial decision-making at Wright State University. One thing he's noticed is that smart people often think they will never fall prey to debt traps. But while financial smarts and self-discipline can certainly play a role in building good habits around money, some of the mental forces that draw us into debt are wired into the unconscious algorithms in our heads.
feedback@hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请写：money。再次重复邮箱地址是：feedback@hiddenbrain.org。约翰·丁斯莫尔在莱特州立大学研究财务决策。他注意到的一件事是，聪明人经常认为自己绝不会落入债务陷阱。但是，虽然金融智慧和自律在围绕金钱建立良好习惯方面确实可以发挥作用，但一些将我们引入债务的心理力量已经深深植根于我们大脑中的无意识算法里。
Becoming aware of them can protect us from problems we didn't see coming. John, I want to talk about a time you and your wife went on a cross-country road trip. It turned into something of an adventure. What was the plan and what happened? So it was during lockdown with COVID, and so you couldn't really fly to anywhere. So we had an SUV and it was rated to be able to tow up to 5,000 pounds. So we decided to rent a camper and tow it down to Florida to see my mother-in-law.
意识到它们的存在可以保护我们免受始料未及的问题的困扰。约翰，我想谈谈你和妻子进行的一次跨国公路旅行。那次旅行变成了一场历险记。当时的计划是什么？发生了什么？那是新冠疫情封锁期间，所以你实际上没法坐飞机去任何地方。所以我们有一辆SUV，它的额定牵引力可达5000磅（约2268公斤）。因此我们决定租一辆露营车，把它拖到佛罗里达去看望我的岳母。
And how did it go? Let's see, we're in Dayton, Ohio. By the time we hit Cincinnati, it was overheating. And we still had to get all the way to South Florida. So it was touch and go for most of the time. And then we made it back. It was a good trip, if a little harrowing. We had to buy a lot of coolant for the SUV.
进展得怎么样？让我想想，我们当时在俄亥俄州代顿。等我们到达辛辛那提时，它已经过热了。而我们还得一路开到南佛罗里达。所以大部分时间都悬念重重、险象环生。不过我们最终还是赶回来了。那是一次不错的旅行，虽然有点惊心动魄。我们不得不为那辆SUV购买了大量的冷却液。
And a few weeks after we got back, we were having lunch, and we looked out, and we just heard a pop. And all of a sudden, there was just auto fluid all over the parking lot. Our car had died. What happened next, John? Did you have to get a new car? Well, first we had it towed to the dealership to have them evaluate it, and they told us, well, it's going to be $14,000 to fix your car. So clearly we weren't going to do that. So it was time to get a new car.
在我们回来几周后，我们正在吃午饭，然后我们望向窗外，只听到“砰”的一声。突然之间，整个停车场到处都是汽车油液。我们的车抛锚了。接下来发生了什么，约翰？你不得不买辆新车吗？嗯，首先我们把它拖到经销商那里让他们评估，他们告诉我们，修理你们的车需要14,000美元。所以显然我们不会那么做。于是是时候买辆新车了。
So we went shopping. But unbeknownst to us, the car market during that time was, cars were very scarce. It was very hard to find a car. So even just to find a car was an achievement, let alone to be able to negotiate a decent price and that sort of thing. I understand that you found a car that was supposed to be extremely reliable. Right. After our SUV had died, we really wanted to, and we had loved the SUV, but it was not the most reliable. So this time, we were going to go for a brand known for reliability. And because cars were so scarce, we saw them roll one off of the truck, and we literally just said, we'll buy it.
所以我们去购物了。但我们不知道的是，那段时期的汽车市场极为短缺，很难买到车。所以能找到一辆车本身就已经是个成就了，更不用说去协商一个像样的价格之类的事情了。据我所知，你找到了一辆据说极其可靠的车。没错。在我们的SUV报废之后，我们真的很想——虽然我们曾深爱那辆SUV，但它并不是最可靠的。所以这一次，我们将选择一个以可靠性著称的品牌。而且因为汽车极度短缺，我们看到一辆车刚从卡车上卸下来，我们literally（简直）就说：我们买下它。
Because it was the only car that the dealership had. I understand that they told you that this was the kind of. reliable car that people give to their grandchildren. So this was a pitch that the car was going to be super safe and last for a very long time. But as the paperwork was coming together, they decided to suggest adding a little protection to the car. Right. When they were trying to convince us to buy the car, it was all about safety and reliability. You know, you can't kill these cars, essentially. And so we committed to buying, we get through the paperwork for buying the car and then came the pitches for all the ad,
因为那是经销商仅有的唯一一辆车。据我了解，他们告诉你这是那种人们会传给孙辈的可靠汽车。所以当时的推销说辞是这款车将超级安全并且能开很长时间。但正当文书工作即将完成时，他们决定建议为这辆车加一点保护。没错。当他们试图说服我们买这辆车时，全都是关于安全和可靠性的。你知道的，基本上就是“这车开不坏”。所以我们承诺购买，我们完成了买车的文书工作，然后就迎来了所有附加产品的推销，
And so what was, this car is indestructible, turned into, but if something goes wrong, it could really ruin you financially. So you're going to want to buy all these extended warranties and protective coatings and all these things. Did you wonder if this car is so reliable? Why are they asking me to buy all these warranties? Yeah, I thought, am I crazy? Like five minutes ago, you were talking about how this thing was the best car on earth.
所以原本“这车坚不可摧”的说法，变成了“但如果出了什么问题，它真的会从财务上毁了你”。所以你会想要购买所有这些延保、保护涂层以及所有这些东西。你有没有想过，如果这辆车这么可靠，为什么他们还要让我买这些质保呢？是的，我想，我是不是疯了？就在五分钟前，你还在谈论这东西是地球上最好的车。
And now it was, boy, you got to watch out, this thing really could set you back if it it breaks down. So talk about this idea because this happens all the time when people buy products, they are rated extremely safe, extremely reliable, but at the point of which people are pulling out their credit cards, we're often told that we should buy an extended warranty. We should buy insurance effectively to protect the car from its own destruction. Talk about the psychological factors that this kind of marketing is playing on, John. Right. So there's a phenomenon known as loss aversion, right, that we hate losing much more than we love winning. And so this is why we typically, if we have stocks that or investments that are
而现在变成了，天哪，你得小心了，这东西如果抛锚真的会让你大伤元气。所以来谈谈这个想法吧，因为当人们购买产品时这种情况一直在发生，它们被评为极其安全、极其可靠，但在人们掏出信用卡的那个时刻，我们经常被告知应该购买延保。我们应该有效地购买保险，以保护汽车免受其自身的毁灭。约翰，谈谈这种营销正在利用的心理因素吧。好的。有一个被称为“损失厌恶”（loss aversion）的现象，即我们对失去的痛苦感受远远大于对得到的快乐感受。这就是为什么通常情况下，如果我们持有的股票或投资正在
gaining, we tend to sell them too early. And if we have investments that are losing, we tend to hold on to them because we just don't want to lose. If we just hang around long enough, it'll come back and it won't be a loss. Well, this also manifests itself in things like buying unnecessary warranties and that sort of a thing. And all of a sudden, you know, buying an extended warranty for however many thousands of dollars for your car, which might have seemed absurd 30 minutes ago, starts to have some appeal to it because, well, for most people, you know, the car is the second biggest purchase they ever make in their lives behind a house. So you don't want that to turn into a loser, so you're willing a lot of times to take on the extra expense of these extended warranties.
盈利，我们往往会过早地卖出它们；而如果我们持有的投资正在亏损，我们往往会死扛着不放，因为我们就是不想接受损失。如果我们再坚持一会儿，它就会回本，那就不是亏损了。好吧，这也体现在购买不必要的质保之类的事情上。突然之间，为你那辆在30分钟前看起来可能还很荒谬的汽车花几千美元购买延保，开始具有了一些吸引力，因为，好吧，对大多数人来说，汽车是他们一生中仅次于房子的第二大开销。所以你不想让它变成一笔失败的买卖，以至于你很多时候愿意承担这些延保的额外费用。
We talked earlier about the disconnect between our present selves and our future cells. You say this plays into a concept called expense prediction bias. What is expense prediction bias, John? Expense prediction bias goes to the fact that we all have too many expenses in life. And so to actually try and keep some sense in your head of what your expenses are is nearly impossible. Now, we are able to quantify in our heads what they call regular expenses. Regular expenses happen at the same time every month for the same amounts. So your mortgage, you're going to remember that.
我们之前讨论过我们现在的自我与未来的自我之间的脱节。你说这涉及一个叫做“开支预测偏误”（expense prediction bias）的概念。约翰，什么是开支预测偏误？开支预测偏误源于这样一个事实：我们在生活中有着太多的开支。因此，要想在脑海中对你的开支保持清醒的认识几乎是不可能的。现在，我们能够在脑海中量化他们所谓的“规律性开支”（regular expenses）。规律性开支每个月都在同一时间以相同的金额发生。所以你的房贷，你会记得。
Your electric bill, you're going to remember that because they happen at the same time for the same amounts. But most of our expenses are actually irregular, right? Car repairs, travel, entertainment, health care. They happen every month, but they don't happen at the same times and for the same amounts. And so when we try and quantify these things in our heads, we massively underestimate what our actual expenses are. And so when we're looking at taking on debt or making a... a big purchase that requires financing, we tend to dramatically underestimate our ability to pay for things.
你的电费，你会记得，因为它们在同一时间以相同的金额发生。但我们的大多数开支其实都是“不规律的”（irregular），对吧？汽车修理、旅游、娱乐、医疗保健。它们每个月都会发生，但不会在相同的时间以相同的金额发生。因此，当我们试图在脑海中量化这些东西时，我们极大地低估了我们的实际开支。所以当我们要承担债务或进行需要融资的大宗采购时，我们往往会戏剧性地低估自己支付费用的能力。
So this is not so much something that marketers are doing to us. It's just something that we are doing to ourselves. In some ways, we are overestimating our capacity to pay for our debts in the future. Right. We are all at a disadvantage when trying to figure these things out. And it's not because we lack intelligence or background. It's just, there's just too many things to be able to keep straight in your head. So if you're trying to make an itemized list of all your expenses, you're not going to be able to do it.
所以这与其说是营销人员对我们做了什么，不如说是我们自己在对自己做些什么。在某些方面，我们高估了自己未来偿还债务的能力。没错。当我们试图弄清楚这些事情时，我们都处于不利地位。这并不是因为我们缺乏智商或背景，而是因为脑海中有太多事情需要理清。因此，如果你试图列出所有开支的明细清单，你是做不到的。
One idea that we have circled around over and over in this conversation, John, is the idea of self-control. And of course, we've talked about self-control previously on Hidden Brain, but talk about how self-control affects our ability to deal with debt and to handle our expenses. So self-control is something that enables us to be able to hold off committing to. something. But we tend to think of self-control as being a stable personality trait when actually it's a reflection of where we are in the moment. Over the course of a day, a lot of times if we're dealing with a lot of complicated issues or facing some difficulties, our self-control can actually degrade over the course of the day. So even if you are a very disciplined person, you still are going to find yourself in moments where maybe you are more impulsive than maybe you normally would be.
约翰，在这次谈话中，我们反复探讨的一个概念就是自控力。当然，我们以前在《隐藏的大脑》中也讨论过自控力，但请谈谈自控力如何影响我们应对债务和处理开支的能力。自控力能让我们有能力暂缓做出某种承诺。但我们往往把自控力看作是一种稳定的性格特征，而实际上它是我们当下状态的反映。在一天当中，很多时候，如果我们正在处理许多复杂的问题或面临一些困难，我们的自控力其实会在一天当中逐渐下降。因此，即使你是一个非常自律的人，你仍然会发现自己在某些时刻可能比平时更容易冲动。
I understand there was one study where gamblers were offered a drink at a casino and it changed how they behaved subsequently. Right. So if you've ever been to Vegas or to any casino, the adage is that once you start winning, then free drinks start coming to you. And people see that for what it is, right? A chance to maybe degrade people's judgment and have them make bigger bets than they normally would. But a study found that even offering a drinker a drink and them saying, no, the act of resisting that degraded their decision-making going forward. I want to talk about the role of compound interest, John. Many of us have learned about compound interest in school or college, of course, but there's something about compound interest
据我了解，曾有一项研究发现，赌场里有人向赌徒提供饮料，这改变了他们随后的行为。没错。如果你去过拉斯维加斯或任何赌场，俗话说得好，一旦你开始赢钱，免费饮料就会送上门来。人们也看穿了这一点，对吧？这无非是想削弱人们的判断力，让他们下比平时更大的注。但一项研究发现，即使是向一个人提供一杯饮料而对方拒绝了，拒绝这个动作本身也会损害他们接下来做决策的能力。约翰，我想谈谈复利的作用。当然，我们很多人在学校或大学里都学过复利，但复利总有一些
that always feels unintuitive, that it feels difficult to wrap our minds around. Right. There's a quote that's often attributed to Albert Einstein, which is compound interest is the eighth wonder of the world. And the reason why it's a mystery to so many people is interest is a price on money. And most prices we encounter is something that we incur once. But compounding interest is a price that is applied to the amount of money that you borrow, and it's reapplied constantly. And over time, as interest rates are applied again and again, it becomes exponentially more expensive than we would anticipate. So most people do not understand the true effects of compounding interest. How does this affect our ability to deal with debt?
让人觉得很不直观的地方，总觉得难以理解。没错。有一句常被归功于阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦的名言，那就是复利是世界的第八大奇迹。它对这么多人来说之所以是个谜，是因为利息是金钱的价格。我们遇到的大多数价格都是只发生一次的费用。但复利是一种应用于你所借金额的价格，而且它在不断地被重新应用。随着时间的推移，利率被一次又一次地应用，它变得比我们预期的要昂贵得多，呈指数级增长。因此，大多数人并不理解复利的真实影响。这如何影响我们应对债务的能力？
because so much of debt, of course, is about compound interest, and sometimes you're not just paying interest on the principle that you borrowed. Sometimes you're paying interest on the interest. Correct. So if you would ask, let's say, you know, someone who's looking to buy their first house, and let's say it was a $200,000 house, let's say 6%. If you ask the person how much interest they would pay on their loan, they might say, well, $6,000, $200,000, okay, that's going to be $12,000 of interest.
因为很大一部分债务当然都与复利有关，而且有时你支付的不仅是你借入的本金的利息。有时你还在支付利息的利息。没错。因此，如果你去问一个准备买第一套房子的人，比方说是一套20万美元的房子，假设利率是6%。如果你问这个人他们要在贷款上支付多少利息，他们可能会说，嗯，6,000美元，200,000美元，好吧，那就是12,000美元的利息。
No, it's actually about $232,000 of interest on top of the $200,000, right? But like with trying to predict our own expenses, there's just too many components to it and the prices applied too many times for someone to have a real grip on how much it's costing them. One of the things that you talk about is the role of rewards programs and how they hijack our brain's desire to pursue financial goals. Talk about this. Everything, from airline miles to, you know, getting the 10th coffee free once you buy nine coffees at the local cafe. So if we're going to go with the example of, say, a free 10th coffee after you buy nine, research shows on rewards programs that not only will that reward program keep you loyal to that cafe,
不，在20万美元之外，实际上大约还要支付232,000美元的利息，对吧？但就像预测我们自己的开支一样，其中的组成部分实在太多了，价格应用得也太频繁了，以至于人们很难真正掌握它到底花掉了他们多少钱。你谈论的事情之一是奖励计划的作用，以及它们如何劫持了我们大脑追求财务目标的欲望。谈谈这个吧。从航空里程，到在当地咖啡馆买九杯咖啡后免费获得第十杯咖啡，无所不包。因此，如果我们以买九杯免费送第十杯咖啡为例，关于奖励计划的研究表明，该奖励计划不仅能让你对那家咖啡馆保持忠诚，
but you will actually increase the frequency of your visits to that cafe as you approach receiving the reward. So that's coffee. if we're looking at credit cards and say miles for travel and that sort of thing, you also find that people increase their purchases and the size and frequency of their purchases as they get closer to some milestone reward, say, like a free plane ticket or something like that. Do you have a personal example of doing this yourself, John? I will say on the retail side in Ohio, there's Grater's Ice Cream, which I think they're nationwide now, but they're from Cincinnati.
而且随着你越来越接近获得奖励，你实际上会增加去那家咖啡馆的频率。所以这是咖啡。如果我们看看信用卡、旅行里程之类的东西，你也会发现，当人们接近某个里程碑式的奖励（比如一张免费机票之类的时候），他们会增加购买量以及购买的规模和频率。约翰，你有没有自己做过这方面的个人例子？我想说的是在俄亥俄州的零售业，有一家Graeter's冰淇淋店，我想他们现在已经开到全国各地了，但他们发源于辛辛那提。
and they give you a free ice cream on your birthday. And even if I've already had ice cream cake and I'm not hungry at all, I make such a point of getting to graders to have my free birthday ice cream, even if it makes me ill. So I am as susceptible as anyone. So it's interesting when we cash in on these benefits, when you get the free ice cream that you don't want on your birthday or you get the 10th cup of coffee,
他们在你生日那天送你一支免费的冰淇淋。即便我之前已经吃过冰淇淋蛋糕而且一点也不饿，我还是会特意去Graeter's吃我的免费生日冰淇淋，哪怕这会让我感到不舒服。所以我跟任何人一样容易受到影响。因此，当我们兑现这些福利时，当你拿到你在生日那天并不想要的免费冰淇淋，或者你得到了第十杯咖啡时，这很有趣。
we view these as financial windfalls. but in fact, we're the ones doing the paying. Absolutely, right. But you get this reward. Winning prizes is fun. Now, if you put it in the credit context, these rewards are harmless if you pay your balance off every month, but I think it's like two-thirds of credit card holders
我们把这些看作是意外之财。但事实上，付钱的人是我们自己。完全正确。但你得到了这个奖励。赢得奖品很有趣。现在，如果你把它放在信贷的语境下，如果你每个月都还清余额，这些奖励是无害的，但我认为大约有三分之二的信用卡持有人
carry balances forward. So for what would be a $200 or $300 round-trip ticket, people end up paying thousands of dollars in interest for it. We've talked a lot about how our brains work against us when it comes to financial decisions, but it's not just that we have these biases. It's also that money itself does something to us. It changes how we behave. You ran a study once about hormone levels and financial status. Describe the study to me and what you found. Okay, so we took a control group and a treatment group and had everyone give saliva tests to measure their testosterone.
会将余额结转到下期。因此，对于一张本来只需200或300美元的往返机票，人们最终为此支付了数千美元的利息。我们已经讨论了很多关于我们的大脑在面对财务决策时如何与我们作对的问题，但这不仅是因为我们有这些偏差。这也是因为金钱本身对我们有某种影响。它改变了我们的行为方式。你曾经做过一项关于荷尔蒙水平与经济地位的研究。请向我描述一下这项研究以及你的发现。好的，我们选取了一个对照组和一个实验组，让每个人都进行唾液测试来测量他们的睾酮水平。
And then one group, we had them handle just stacks of paper in the dimensions of dollar bills. The other group, we had them handle stacks of $20 bills. And the people who handled $20 bills experienced a rise in testosterone when they handled money. And that rise in testosterone made them more aggressive and more self-focused and less likely to donate to charity. Why do you think this happens, John? Why is handling money versus handling paper that's the same dimensions, the same size as money? Why does it have this effect on us? So this study is done in a field known as evolutionary psychology. Evolutionary psychology looks at what are behaviors endemic to humans that maybe go back to when we're living in caves. So when we were living in caves, the more status you had amongst the other cavemen and women, the more resources flow to you, the less you cooperative you had to be, and the less you had to consider others. Well, back, then status is probably about, you know, physical dominance.
然后，我们让其中一组人只处理一叠叠纸币尺寸的纸张。另一组人则处理一叠叠20美元的钞票。处理20美元钞票的人在接触金钱时，其睾酮水平有所上升。睾酮水平的上升使他们更具攻击性、更关注自我，也更不可能向慈善机构捐款。约翰，你认为为什么会这样？为什么处理金钱与处理尺寸、大小与金钱相同的纸张会有这种区别？为什么它会对我们产生这种影响？这项研究是在一个被称为进化心理学的领域中进行的。进化心理学研究的是人类特有的行为，这些行为或许可以追溯到我们住在山洞里的时期。所以当我们住在山洞里时，你在其他山洞男女中的地位越高，流向你的资源就越多，你需要合作的程度就越低，你需要考虑别人的地方也就越少。嗯，在当时，地位可能主要关乎体力优势。
Now, status is more determined by economic resources. So people handling large sums of money experience a rise in testosterone, and they become more focused on themselves and less concerned with others. Do you think most people have a good sense of how their own minds are working when it comes to debt and money, John? Probably not, right? there's lots of things that we that influence us without our knowing it i mean as someone who does research on marketing and reads lots of research on marketing you see things that you know tiny influences that change people's preferences and choices without them being willing to acknowledge
现在，地位更多地由经济资源来决定。因此，处理大量金钱的人体内的睾酮水平会上升，他们会变得更专注于自己，而对他人漠不关心。约翰，你认为大多数人在面对债务和金钱时，对自己的大脑是如何运作的有很好的认识吗？可能没有，对吧？有许多事情在不知不觉中影响着我们。我的意思是，作为一个研究营销并阅读大量营销研究的人，你会看到一些事情——你知道，微小的影响就能改变人们的偏好和选择，而他们却不愿意承认
that it does affect them so you know if you look at well when we talked about intertemporal discounting you know how you time things can lead to what you call a preference reversal. In scenario A, people want the first choice, but you take that same person and you put them in a different context and they want different things. If you ask people to choose the best option versus eliminate the worst options, they end up making different choices. You know, what is the default choice within an array of options? Usually carries a lot of power. one of my favorites was Starbucks introduced the Trenta, I guess, which is the extra large coffee. And it didn't sell a lot of Trentas.
这确实对他们产生了影响。所以你看，当我们谈到跨期贴现时，你知道你安排时间的方式会导致你所谓的偏好逆转。在情景A中，人们想要第一个选择，但如果你把同一个人放在不同的情景中，他们就会想要不同的东西。如果你让人们在最佳选项和排除最差选项之间做出选择，他们最终会做出不同的选择。你知道，一系列选项中的默认选择通常具有很大的影响力。我最喜欢的一个例子是，星巴克推出了“特伦塔”（Trenta），我猜那是超大杯咖啡。然而并没有卖出很多特伦塔。
What it actually did was it sold a lot of what used to be the large coffee because all of a sudden it seemed like a more moderate option, even though it was still 20 ounces or whatever it was because it was no longer the extreme or endpoint option, they viewed it as moderate. some more people started buying it. I mean, in some ways, what you're saying is that marketers are taking advantage of these natural gremlins that are in our heads. Yes. I mean, and we are required to make decisions about and pass judgment on things that we can't be experts on. There's too many things to make choices about.
它实际做到的是，它卖出了大量过去被认为是大杯的咖啡，因为突然之间它看起来像是一个更温和的选择，尽管它仍然是20盎司左右。因为它不再是极端或终极选项，人们认为它很温和。于是更多的人开始买它。我的意思是，从某种程度上说，你所说的意思是营销人员正在利用我们头脑中这些自然的“小恶魔”。是的。我的意思是，我们需要对那些我们不可能成为专家的事物做出决定并进行判断。有太多事情需要做出选择。
And because of that, we tend to look for little signals to guide our choices just so that we feel like it's based in something. and a lot of times those little signals that we see on are irrelevant. It's nice to believe that being good with money comes down to basic literacy. Learn how to crunch some numbers, make a budget, and exercise a little discipline, and you'll be good. But often enough, financial literacy is not enough to combat the biases that shape our decisions and the marketers who know how to take advantage of our mistakes. When we come back, strategies for fighting back.
正因为如此，我们往往会寻找一些小的信号来指导我们的选择，好让我们觉得它是建立在某种基础上的。而且很多时候，我们在上面看到的那些小信号是无关紧要的。人们总愿意相信，精明理财不过是基本的理算能力。学会算算数、做个预算、再施以一点自律，你就能理好财。但通常情况下，金融素养并不足以对抗塑造我们决策的偏差，也不足以对抗那些深知如何利用我们失误的营销人员。稍后我们将为您带来反击的策略。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you had an experience in your life where you thought you were getting a great deal only to find yourself mired in debt? Have you found ways to protect yourself
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你的生活中是否有过这样的经历：你以为自己捡了个大便宜，结果却发现自己深陷债务泥潭？你是否找到了保护自己
from getting in over your head financially? If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email the audio file to us, using the email address,
免受财务过度透支的方法？如果你有一个愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享的个人故事，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录下一条语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。请将音频文件通过电子邮件发送给我们，电子邮箱地址是：
Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, money. Again, that email address is feedback at hiddenbrain.org. We are taught that being good with money is about making smart choices. Spend less, save more, avoid debt.
Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请写：money。再次重复该邮箱地址是：feedback@hiddenbrain.org。我们受到的教育是，精明理财在于做出明智的选择。少花钱、多存钱、避免负债。
On paper, that's true, but real life isn't a spreadsheet. In his book, The Marketing of Debt, how they get you, John Dinsmore says, that being good with money isn't just about knowing what to do on paper. It's also about resisting the forces that lure us into self-sabotage. John, when you buy a house, you're not
从纸面上看，这是对的，但现实生活不是电子表格。约翰·丁斯莫尔（John Dinsmore）在他的书《债务营销：他们是如何套牢你的》（The Marketing of Debt, how they get you）中说，精明理财不仅仅要知道纸面上该做什么。它还在于抵制那些诱使我们陷入自我破坏的力量。约翰，当你买房子时，你不仅
only thinking about how much it costs, you're also thinking about home inspections and repairs and the quality of local schools and whether you're going to get along with your new neighbors. Can you talk about the role of exhaustion when it comes to the financial mistakes we make? Yeah, and housing or buying a house is probably the best. example of it. There are so many things to do, and it's such an important purchase in someone's life. All of these things make it what psychologists would call like a depleting process, right? And the more complex something becomes, the more energy we have to dedicate to it, the greater likelihood that we're going to have a breakdown in our self-control. The psychologist Donna Webster
在考虑它花了多少钱，你还要考虑房屋检查、维修、当地学校的质量，以及你是否能和新邻居相处融洽。你能谈谈在我们做出财务失误时，疲劳所起到的作用吗？是的，住房或买房可能是最好的例子。有太多事情要做，而且这是一个人一生中如此重要的购买。所有这一切使它成为心理学家所说的“消耗过程”，对吧？事情变得越复杂，我们需要投入的精力就越多，我们的自控力崩溃的可能性也就越大。心理学家唐娜·韦伯斯特
and Ari Kroglanski referred to this as seizing and freezing, where we basically have a lot of a desire to bring the process to a conclusion because we're so tired, we're so exhausted. Yes. And what the seizing and freezing refers to is when you're not sure what's important, you will seize upon one piece of information and then you will freeze out everything else. So because you're so glad to bring things to resolution that a lot of times you're unwilling to consider new information that would help you make a better decision. I'm wondering if the same thing happens when people buy cars. You know, the process starts out being very fun.
（Donna Webster）和阿里·克罗格兰斯基（Ari Kruglanski）将此称为“抓住与冻结”（seizing and freezing），也就是因为我们太累了、太精疲力竭了，所以我们基本上非常渴望让这个过程得出结论。是的。“抓住与冻结”指的是当你对什么重要感到不确定时，你会抓住一条信息，然后将其他一切信息都“冻结”或屏蔽在外。因此，因为你如此高兴能将事情解决，以至于很多时候你都不愿意考虑那些能帮你做出更好决策的新信息。我想知道人们买车时是否也会发生同样的情况。你知道，这个过程一开始是非常有趣的。
You're taking the car for a spin. You're being told about all the nice things about the car. You get the feel of a new car, the smell of a new car. It's all very exciting. But then after you've spent an hour exploring how fun the car is, the process of actually negotiating the purchase of the car begins, including financing terms and a whole bunch of other things. Absolutely.
你开着车兜风。别人向你介绍汽车的所有优点。你感受着新车的手感，新车的味道。这一切都非常令人兴奋。但当你花了一个小时探索这辆车的乐趣之后，真正开始协商购买汽车的流程就开始了，包括融资条款和一大堆其他事情。绝对是的。
And chances are this was not the first dealership you were at, that day, right? You've been looking for a while and doing this again and again. And at some point, I mean, it could even be that the car you choose is the result of exhaustion and a breakdown in self-control. But even if it's not, then you get into being offered all of the extras and all of these options. And, you know, it makes it harder and harder to make good decisions going forward. And of course, the vast majority of new cars are financed. So now you actually have to negotiate the terms of an auto loan. Is it four years? Is it five years? Is it six years? They're interest rates, the different monthly payments.
而且很有可能这并不是你那天去的家第一家车 dealership（车行），对吧？你已经找了一段时间，而且一次又一次地这样做。在某个时刻，我的意思是，甚至可能是你选择的车正是疲劳和自控力崩溃的结果。但即使不是这样，接下来你就会面临被推销各种额外配置和所有这些选项的情况。而且，你知道，这使得你以后越来越难以做出好的决定。当然，绝大多数新车都是通过贷款购买的。所以现在你实际上必须就汽车贷款的条款进行谈判。是四年？五年？还是六年？还有利率，以及不同的每月还款额。
Absolutely. And if you haven't done your homework, and a lot of times people haven't, it means you could take on more expensive loans than you would have to otherwise. What can we do to resist getting sold something we don't really want or need when we are exhausted, John? Well, I think there's a few things that you can do. So, well, one thing is you can take a break. You can defer. So if we're going with the car scenario when they start trying to sell, you all these add-on things, you can say, you know what, can I come back to you later? Let's move forward right now, but can I come back later?
绝对是的。如果你没有做好功课——而人们很多时候确实没做功课，这意味着你可能会承担比原本不必要承担的更昂贵的贷款。约翰，当我们精疲力竭时，我们能做些什么来抵制被推销我们并不真正想要或不需要的东西呢？嗯，我认为你可以做几件事情。所以，嗯，其中一件事就是你可以休息一下。你可以推迟。所以，如果我们以汽车销售的场景为例，当他们开始试图向你推销所有这些附加东西时，你可以说，你知道吗，我能晚点再回复你吗？我们现在继续进行，但我能晚点再来吗？
This will give you a chance to take a break. It will also put off the salesperson. The salesperson will always tell you that you can change your mind later about the warranties or whatever. But in the meantime, it'll help you just get past that hard sales pitch. And another thing that you can do is if you're starting to feel too exhausted and you find yourself focusing on being exhausted and maybe you could get, ah, I'm so tired, right? A lot of times it's helpful just to walk outside and give yourself a little pep talk. Studies have shown that the more
这会给你一个休息的机会。它也会让推销员暂缓攻势。推销员总是会告诉你，你以后可以改变主意不要保修或别的什么。但与此同时，这将帮助你度过那个强力推销的关头。你能做的另一件事是，如果你开始感到精疲力竭，并且发现自己把注意力集中在筋疲力尽上，或许你会想：“啊，我太累了”，对吧？很多时候，走出去呼吸一下新鲜空气并对自己进行一番自我鼓励（pep talk）是很有帮助的。研究表明，你越是
you perseverate on being in a weakened condition, the more weakened you actually become. But if you can actually, you know, give yourself a pep talk and tell yourself that you can do this and take a little time to compose yourself, you're going to make better decisions. Many complex financial deals involved doing math, and many people hate doing math. One study looked at brain scans of people as they were doing difficult math problems. Tell me what it found, John. So one study did an fMRI of people who said they had math anxiety and asked them to do math problems, and it lit up the threat detection.
执着于自己处于虚弱状态，你就会变得越虚弱。但如果你实际上能够，你知道，给自己打打气，告诉自己你能做到这一点，并花点时间让自己平静下来，你就会做出更好的决定。许多复杂的金融交易都涉及数学计算，而很多人讨厌数学。有一项研究观察了人们在做困难的数学题时的脑部扫描。约翰，告诉我它发现了什么。因此，一项研究对那些自称有数学焦虑症的人进行了fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）扫描，让他们做数学题，结果点亮了他们大脑中的威胁检测
centers of their brain. So it was like they were being chased by a tiger because they were so intimidated and overwhelmed at the notion of doing math, which if you're dealing with financial questions can be a real problem. I mean, I've often received documentation for various things, and the documentation runs for five pages, and there's fine print and all kinds of numbers, and it's not surprising in some ways that your brain seizes up and says, oh my God, this is the last thing I want to be reading and thinking about. Absolutely. And we all know the phrase stress makes you stupid. It doesn't actually make you stupid, but it does limit your abilities. You're not as capable as you normally would be to deal with
中心。所以这就好像他们被老虎追赶一样，因为他们对做数学题的概念感到如此恐吓和不堪重负，如果你正在处理财务问题，这可能会是一个真正的问题。我的意思是，我经常收到各种文件的资料，这些资料长达五页，上面有小字和各种各样的数字，在某种程度上，你的大脑会当机并说“天哪，这是我最不想阅读和思考的事情”，这也就不足为奇了。绝对是的。我们都知道“压力使人变笨”这句话。它实际上并不会让你变笨，但它确实会限制你的能力。你处理像房屋贷款这样的大问题时的能力会不如平时。约翰，请简单谈谈营销人员是如何利用我们对简单的渴望的。作为一名营销人员，通常如果你想真正突出某样东西并让人们理解和记住某样东西，你会把事情弄得尽可能简单，对吧？而金融产品的定价并不简单。事实上，通常有多个价格组成部分、不同的费用以及诸如此类的事情。因此，债务营销人员有时会做的是在前期放一个非常诱人的价格，因为我们会抓住那个简单的信息并屏蔽掉所有其他信息，然后深藏在小字中
issues like home loans. Talk a little bit about how marketers take advantage of our desire for simplicity, John. As a marketer, typically if you want to really highlight something and get people to understand and remember something, you make things as simple as possible, right? And pricing for financial products is not simple. In fact, there's usually multiple components of price, different fees, and that sort of thing. So what marketers of debt will sometimes do is put a very attractive price up front and because we will take that simple piece of information and block out everything else, then deep in the fine print
或者网站的其他部分，或者无论哪里，你都会看到所有那些实际上会使费用升级的附加条款。但它们会让我们觉得自己听懂了某样东西，而实际上我们并没有。换句话说，有人告诉我某事享有0%的介绍性利率，
or other parts of the website or wherever you'll see all the kickers that actually escalate the expensive things. But they will make us feel like we understand something when we actually don't. So in other words, I'm told that something has a 0% introductory rate
而我把注意力集中在0%上，却没有注意到“介绍性”（introductory）这个词。没错。我们会认为利率就是0%而离开，尽管事实上这只在比如三个月内有效，之后就会涨到20%左右之类的情况。这与被称为“分区定价”（partition pricing）的概念有关吗，约翰？
and I focus on the 0% and not on the word introductory. Right. We will walk away thinking of 0% despite the fact that that's only good for, say, three months and then it goes up to 20%. or something like that. Is this related to the idea called partition pricing, John?
是的。所以分区定价是指一个产品有多个价格组成部分，对吧？所以如果你想想看，如果有人在商场里买鞋，他们看到鞋子带回家需要55美元。但如果你在一个网站上购物，鞋子标价为50美元加上10美元运费，人们往往会选择那双实际花费他们60美元的50美元鞋子，因为他们看到了第一个价格，这就是他们编码的方式，他们认为这比商场里55美元的鞋子更便宜。因此在某种程度上，这有点像魔术。
Yes. So partition pricing is where a product has multiple components of price, right? So if you think of it, if someone is shopping for shoes in the mall and they see that the shoes are $55 to take home. But you're shopping on a website and the shoes are listed as $50 plus $10 shipping, people will often go for the $50 shoes that actually cost them $60 because they see that first price, and that's how they encode it, and they think of that as being cheaper than the $55 shoes in the mall. So in some ways, it's a little bit like a magic trick.
如果你是一名营销人员，分区定价可以让你隐藏商品的真实成本。是的，我们通常只能在记忆中为一个产品编码一个价格。所以我们看到了一个价格，然后我们就停止了
If you're a marketer, partition pricing allows you to hide the real cost of the item. Yes, we typically can only encode one price for a product in our memories. So we see the one price, and then we stop. looking for other things or don't take other things into account. How do we get around this problem? How do we, given the fact that we have these limitations, that we focus on things that are right in front of us, we have this desire for simplicity, we don't like to do math. How do we solve this? I wish I had a more attractive answer for you, but the answer is to do the math and to do the work. If you're aware of these biases or shortcomings, you're more likely to be able to process them
寻找其他东西或不再把其他东西考虑在内。我们如何绕过这个问题？鉴于我们有这些局限性——我们关注就在眼前的事物、我们渴望简单、我们不喜欢做数学题——我们该如何解决这个问题？我希望我能给你一个更有吸引力的答案，但答案是：做数学题，并付出努力。如果你意识到这些偏差或缺点，你就更有可能处理好它们
and deal well. I mean, one of my, one of the studies that I came across was from a couple of economists named Stango and Zinman. And what they found was the price that people pay for debt, the biggest factor is how much effort people put into shopping for debt. It's not your credit score. We tend to think of credit scores as something, you know, that comes down from heaven, and it is what it's going to be, and that's the price we pay for things. It's more about effort and shopping around and finding competitive pricing. In other words, if someone offers you a loan or a mortgage, make sure that you are doing some price comparisons to make sure that there isn't another loan next door. That's a better rate for you. Absolutely. I mean, my story about buying the house, the truth is we probably,
并应对得当。我的意思是，我遇到的研究之一是来自两位名为斯坦戈（Stango）和津曼（Zinman）的经济学家。他们的发现是，人们为债务支付的价格，其中最大的因素是人们在货比三家寻找债务上付出了多少努力。这并不是你的信用评分。我们往往认为信用评分是某种……你知道的，从天而降的东西，它就是那样了，这就是我们为事物支付的价格。它更多地关乎努力、货比三家以及找到有竞争力的定价。换句话说，如果有人向你提供一笔贷款或抵押贷款，请确保你进行了一些价格比较，以确保隔壁没有另一家提供更好利率的贷款。绝对是的。我的意思是，我买房子的故事，事实是，我们可能——
we did have options. We could have shopped around, but we felt like we couldn't. Some years later, we're living in Ohio and we got to refinance our house here, and we dealt with a mortgage broker who at the last second wanted to introduce an extra $1,500 fee. And we just walked because we knew better. I mean, we had learned the hard way. And we found a mortgage with a lower interest rate as a result from walking away. One of the phenomena that you have studied is something called the endowment effect. We've talked about this previously on Hidden Brain.
我们确实有选择。我们本可以货比三家，但我们觉得自己做不到。几年后，我们住在俄亥俄州，我们不得不在这里重新贷款我们的房子，我们和一个按揭经纪人打交道，他在最后一秒钟想要引入额外的1500美元费用。我们直接走人了，因为我们更懂行。我的意思是，我们是从痛苦的经历中吸取了教训。结果，我们通过走人找到了一家利率更低的按揭贷款。你研究过的现象之一是一种叫做“禀赋效应”（endowment effect）的东西。我们以前在《隐藏的大脑》中讨论过这一点。
Talk about the role of the endowment effect in debt and how we can deal with it as consumers. Okay, so the endowment effect, again, we hate losing much more than we love winning. So if you look at the Queen of Versailles example, at some point where things start to go south with the tower in Vegas, all of the associates of David Siegel are saying, why don't you just sell this tower? This would solve all of our problems. And he refuses to. It's his. He tends to think it's more valuable than it is.
请谈谈禀赋效应在债务中的作用，以及作为消费者我们该如何应对它。好的，那么禀赋效应，再次说明，我们讨厌失去远甚于我们喜欢获胜。所以如果你看看凡尔赛女王的例子，在韦加斯的塔楼事情开始变糟的某个时刻，大卫·西格尔的所有合伙人都说，你为什么不把这座塔卖掉呢？这会解决我们所有的问号。而他拒绝了。这是他的。他倾向于认为它比实际价值更高。
and, you know, the market will tell you what it's worth. And so he holds on to it and holds on to it, creating lots of financial stress for everyone. And the tower ultimately gets foreclosed upon a couple of years later. Because it was his and it was so valuable to him, he wouldn't make what was to everyone else a very obvious and common sense decision of getting rid of this thing that you couldn't afford. I mean, there have been multiple studies that have been conducted
而且，你知道，市场会告诉你它的价值是多少。所以他紧抓不放，死死抓住不放，给每个人都造成了巨大的财务压力。几年后，这座塔最终被法院止赎了。因为它属于他，并且对他来说如此有价值，所以他不会做出对其他人来说非常显而易见且符合常识的决定——摆脱这个你负担不起的东西。我的意思是，已经有多项研究进行了
that show that if you give somebody even, you know, a trivial thing, a trinket, a pen, an eraser, within seconds, they start to assign value to that pen or that eraser so that if they were to part with it, they would want to be compensated for parting with this thing. And in some ways, it's the endowment effect, again, that once you have something that's part of your endowment, part of your property, if you will, you tend to want to guard it zealously. Yes, and even if that thing is draining you of all of your resources. But because it's yours, you think it's more valuable than anyone else does, and so you tend to hold on to it when you shouldn't. Now, one of the interesting ideas you explore, John, is that we can sometimes use the endowment effect and loss aversion to our advantage, especially when it comes to retirement savings.
结果表明，如果你给某人哪怕是微不足道的东西，一个饰品、一支笔、一块橡皮，在几秒钟之内，他们就会开始给这支笔或这块橡皮赋予价值，以至于如果他们要与之分道扬镳，他们会要求得到补偿才肯放弃这东西。从某种程度上说，这又是禀赋效应，一旦你拥有了某种属于你的禀赋、属于你的财产的东西，如果你愿意的话，你往往会狂热地守护它。是的，即使那个东西正在耗尽你所有的资源。但因为它是你的，你认为它比其他任何人都更有价值，所以在你不该坚持的时候，你往往会坚持。现在，你探讨的一个有趣的观点是，约翰，我们有时可以利用禀赋效应和损失厌恶来为我们自己谋取利益，尤其是在退休储蓄方面。
How so? So there's an ability to take a lot of these phenomena and kind of turn them around and use them to help you, right? So with the endowment effect, when you get money, it's harder to let go of that money. So if you're looking at something like saving for retirement, once the money hits your account, if you have to actually then write a check to put money into a savings account or a retirement account, you become less likely to do so. A reason why Social Security has been such a successful program is because it is money for retirement taken out of people's checks before they get them, right? So you can do this for yourself by having automated savings, whether it's college fund for the kids, your retirement, or just savings in general, and have the money taken out of your check before it gets to your account.
怎么说呢？所以我们有能力把很多这种现象某种程度上扭转过来并利用它们来帮助你，对吧？所以在禀赋效应中，当你拿到钱时，要放手这笔钱就更难了。因此，如果你在考虑像为退休存钱这样的事情，一旦钱打到了你的账户里，如果你必须实际写一张支票把钱存入储蓄账户或退休账户，你这样做的可能性就会降低。社会保障之所以如此成功，是因为它是从人们拿到支票之前就扣除了用于退休的钱，对吧？所以你可以为自己做到这一点，通过设置自动储蓄——无论是给孩子们的大学基金、你的退休金，还是单纯的一般储蓄——并在钱到达你的账户之前就从你的支票中扣除。
And when that happens, people don't miss the money as much as they would if it had hit their account and they find that over time they're able to save a lot more as a result. in other words, if my salary is, let's say, $1,000, instead of having the $1,000 come to my account, and then have to, you know, write a check for $200 to my savings or to my retirement account, what you're saying is it's helpful to set things up so that that $200 gets deducted up front, and I only receive a salary of $800, and I don't think of that $1,000 as my endowment now. I think of it as just $800. Right, right. So and probably most people have had the experience of you get a raise and you think, all right, but I'm still going through all my money.
当这种情况发生时，人们不会像钱已经打到账户里那样对这笔钱感到惋惜，而且他们发现，随着时间的推移，他们因此能够存下更多的钱。换句话说，如果我的薪水比方说是1000美元，这1000美元不是先打到我的账户里，然后我不得不……你知道的，写一张200美元的支票存到我的储蓄账户或退休账户，你所说的意思是，最好把事情设置好，让这200美元在前端就被扣除，我只收到800美元的薪水，而且我不再把那1000美元视为我的禀赋。我只把它视为800美元。对，对。所以，而且可能大多数人都有过这种经历：你加薪了，然后你心想，好吧，但我所有的钱还是花光了。
And you, it's because when the money comes into your account, there's always something that's, you know, legitimate that's there to have money to be spent on. But the truth is, if it's put away in an account, a savings account away from you, you're going to figure out how to make due on the money that you have. Talk about the role of status-branded credit cards, John. How do they work and what should we do about them? So if you think back to the American Express Gold Card, which was the real first status-branded card, it was a massive success. It immediately became this status symbol in the culture, right?
而且你，这是因为当钱打入你的账户时，总有一些合情合理的事情需要把钱花在上面。但事实是，如果它被存放在一个远离你的账户、一个储蓄账户里，你就会想办法靠手头现有的钱过日子。约翰，请谈谈带有地位品牌的信用卡的作用。它们是如何运作的，我们应该如何对待它们？所以如果你回想一下美国运通金卡（American Express Gold Card），那是真正意义上的第一张地位品牌卡，它取得了巨大的成功。它立刻成为了文化中的这种身份象征，对吧？
And so what credit card marketers figured out was, wow, people really like these things. So over time, most of your credit cards became, you know, diamond or sapphire or platinum or whatever. And what we found, what studies have shown is that, and this includes credit cards to people with bad credit, with few resources. And what studies have shown is that if you are someone who feels like you're lacking status, like having less money, but you have a status branded card, you have a tendency to use this card a lot more, particularly if you're using it in front of people whose opinion
因此，信用卡营销人员发现的是，哇，人们真的很喜欢这些东西。所以随着时间的推移，你大部分的信用卡都变成了……你知道的，钻石卡、蓝宝石卡、白金卡或其他什么。我们发现的，研究显示的是，并且这包括面向信用不好、资源很少的人的信用卡。研究显示的是，如果你是一个觉得自己缺乏地位、资金较少的人，但你拥有一张地位品牌卡，你就会倾向于大量使用这张卡，特别是如果你是在那些你重视其对你的看法的人面前使用它时
of you, you value. Hmm. In other words, I might not actually have the ability to pay for this super expensive restaurant meal, but I feel good to pull out this flashy credit card and drop it on the table and pick up the check. Absolutely, right? You're sending a strong signal to the people around you, to the people whose opinion you care about. It would be otherwise, you know, would it be like having a Ferrari and never taking it out of the garage? It's a beautiful fast car, yes, but a reason for having a Ferrari a lot of times is so that other people can see you in a Ferrari. And status branded credit cards can be a lot like that. I mean, in some ways, it's a genius marketing move, isn't it? Because it's taking advantage of this desire. we have to look perhaps wealthier and more successful than we actually are in the eyes of other people. Absolutely. I mean, there's a lot of aspirational marketing, you would call it, right? For people who may not have the resources, but who can have this thing that makes it look like they do. And I don't know if branders of credit cards thought more about it other than people like this brand will put this brand on every card.
。嗯。换句话说，我实际上可能没有能力支付这顿超级昂贵的餐厅大餐，但我掏出这张浮夸的信用卡并把它拍在桌上买单，这让我感觉很好。绝对是的，对吧？你正在向你周围的人、向那些你关心其看法的人发出强烈的信号。这在其他情况下会是怎样的呢，你知道的，这就像拥有一辆法拉利却从不把它开出车库一样？它是一辆漂亮的速度快的跑车，是的，但拥有法拉利的一个重要原因往往是为了让别人看到你开着法拉利。而带有地位品牌的信用卡很可能就是这样。从某种程度上说，这是一个天才的营销举动，不是吗？因为它利用了我们内心的这种渴望：在别人眼中，我们看起来比实际情况更富有、更成功。绝对是的。我的意思是，这有很多你可以称之为“渴望型营销”（aspirational marketing）的东西，对吧？对于那些可能没有资源，但却能拥有这样一件东西来让人觉得他们有资源的人来说。我不知道信用卡品牌方除了“人们喜欢这个品牌，我们要把这个品牌印在每张卡上”之外是否还想过更多，
but over time, the data should show them that people with lesser means are using these types of cards more often and more than they can afford. What do you think people should do with their status branded credit cards? Well, the flip side of it is studies have also shown that if you have a credit card that's branded with some sort of value brand, like say, you know, Goodwill or Walmart or something like that, that it reverses the effect. So I be less enticed by a platinum card and more enticed by a card that maybe communicates financial good sense. You know, there's an irony here, John, which is I think the people who might be most drawn to status-branded credit cards are often people who want to show that they have status. And it's probably because in some ways they don't feel like they have status, whereas people who actually might be wealthy or well-off might have less need to demonstrate. straight their status either to themselves or to others. And so precisely the people who need to get the Thrift-branded credit cards are not the people
但随着时间的推移，数据应该会向他们表明，资源较少的人更频繁地使用这类卡片，其使用频率超过了他们的承受能力。你认为人们应该如何处理他们的地位品牌信用卡？嗯，事情的另一面是，研究还表明，如果你有一张印有某种价值品牌的信用卡，比如，你知道的，Goodwill（好运 Goodwill慈善机构）、沃尔玛或类似的东西，它会逆转这种效果。所以我对白金卡的诱惑会减少，而对一张可能传达出良好财务常识的卡片的诱惑会增加。约翰，这里面有一个讽刺意味，那就是我认为最被地位品牌信用卡吸引的人，往往是那些想要展示自己地位的人。这可能在某种程度上是因为他们觉得自己没有地位，而那些实际上可能很富有或境况很好的人，则不那么需要向自己或他人展示他们的地位。因此，确切地说，那些需要获得“节俭”品牌信用卡的人，并不是那些
who are actually getting them. Correct. Yeah. So if you feel like you're lacking in status, it may be that this credit card and just the way it's branded may be one of the, maybe the only signal of status that you can send out to people. So people of lesser means will gravitate towards them. We talked earlier about the optimism bias.
真正获得这些卡的人。没错。是的。因此，如果你觉得自己缺乏地位，可能正是这张信用卡以及它的品牌塑造方式，成为了你能向人们发出的仅有的地位信号之一。因此，资源较少的人会倾向于它们。我们之前讨论过乐观偏差。
We assume the future will be better than the present, and therefore we'll have more money in the future. You say that one way to combat this kind of bias is to seek examples that run counter to it. How would we do this? Right. So psychologists refer to it as counterfactual thinking. So any kind of bias, whether it's optimism or anything else, what's helpful is to challenge yourself to think. of something that is the opposite or like an example that is the opposite of which you're currently thinking. So if you're thinking to yourself, well, I'm going to have lots of disposable income in the
我们假设未来会比现在更好，因此我们在未来会有更多的钱。你说对抗这种偏差的方法之一是寻找与之相反的例子。我们该怎么做呢？对。所以心理学家称之为“反事实思维”（counterfactual thinking）。因此，任何类型的偏差，无论是乐观主义还是其他什么，有帮助的做法是挑战自己去思考
future. You know, ask yourself, well, have you ever had disposable income, right? So these are ways to challenge your notion of the future. If the past or the present can't provide you with any examples of what you're imagining for the future, well, then that will help you have a more restrained or rational approach to things. Is basic financial literacy something that could help us here, John? Absolutely. I think about 25 states have made financial literacy part of high school curricula, which is great. Financial literacy helps. It's certainly better to know than to not know. The other part of it is the effects of financial literacy can fade over time.
与你当前想法相反的事情，或者是与你当前想法相反的例子。所以如果你心里想，嗯，我在未来会有很多可支配收入。你知道，问问你自己，好吧，你以前有过可支配收入吗？所以这些都是挑战你对未来观念的方法。如果过去或现在无法为你想象的未来提供任何例证，好吧，那么这将有助于你对事物采取一种更克制或更理性的态度。基本的金融素养能在这里帮助我们吗，约翰？绝对可以。我认为大约有25个州已将金融素养纳入高中课程，这很棒。金融素养有帮助。了解总比不了解好。另一部分是，金融素养的影响会随着时间推移而淡化。
So it's always worthwhile if you're approaching a significant financial decision to either reacquaint yourself before you do that or to get help from someone who is dealing with those types of decisions all the time. In other words, if you're buying a house, for example, you know, maybe spend 15 bucks and buy a book that basically says, here are financial tips on how you can buy a house. Right, absolutely. And on the other side, the lenders, they live in financial decisions. So they're going to have an inherent advantage. So you need to kind of bone up. Even if you've already read that book, it's good to refresh yourself before decisions like this. I'm wondering with all that you have learned about financial decision making, John, have you made better financial choices in your own life as a result? Well, the worst decisions that I've made often have been because I felt helpless or that maybe I being afraid to ask for help, I think, is part of it too, convincing myself that I understood
因此，如果你即将做出重大的财务决策，在行动之前重新熟悉相关知识，或者向那些一直处理这类决策的人寻求帮助，总是值得的。换句话说，如果你在买房子，比如，你知道的，也许花15块钱买一本书，上面基本上写着：这里有关于你如何买房的理财建议。对，绝对是的。而在另一方面，贷款人，他们就生活在财务决策中。所以他们将拥有天生的优势。因此你需要做点恶补。即使你已经读过那本书，在做出这样的决定之前复习一下也是很好的。约翰，我想知道，通过你所学到的关于财务决策的一切，你自己的生活因此做出了更好的财务选择吗？嗯，我做过的最糟糕的决定往往是因为我感到无助，或者可能害怕寻求帮助也是其中一部分吧，说服自己说我都懂。
something when I really didn't. Often, and I don't think I'm alone, it's embarrassing to ask for help sometimes, but what's more embarrassing, losing $30,000 on a mortgage or asking a friend to look at something for you? One of the themes underlying how we think about money is our aversion to doubt. We don't like to question our assumption that, of course, we'll be making more money a decade from now. We don't want to sit with questions about how much we're actually paying an interest on our dream home. It's uncomfortable to ponder the prospect of future car repairs, so we agree to the expensive warranty that the salesman is pushing.
有时候我真的没有。通常情况下，而且我觉得我不是一个人，有时候向别人寻求帮助会觉得很尴尬，但什么更尴尬呢？在按揭贷款上亏损 3万美元，还是请朋友帮你看看？我们对待金钱的想法背后，有一个主题就是我们对不确定性的抗拒。我们不喜欢质疑这样一种假设：十年后，我们的收入肯定会增加。我们不想去深究我们到底为梦中情房支付了多少利息。思考未来汽车维修的可能性让人感到不舒服，所以我们同意了推销员力推的昂贵保修服务。
What we crave is certainty, in money, in love, and in many other dimensions of our lives. But are there times we should be embracing our doubts? We recently heard a powerful story from a listener named Suzanne. She called in to tell us about a time when she went to get a routine flu shot at her pharmacy. During the pandemic, I went to my pharmacist for my flu shot, and I looked at her and she looked so tired. And I said, you know what, even though we have an appointment, it's late at night, I'm sure I'm your last patient, let me come back tomorrow.
我们渴望的是确定性，在金钱、爱情以及生活的许多其他方面。但有没有什么时候，我们应该拥抱心中的疑虑呢？我们最近听到了听众苏珊（Suzanne）讲述的一个动人的故事。她打电话来告诉我们，有一次她去药店常规接种流感疫苗的经历。在大流行期间，我去找药剂师打流感疫苗，我看着她，她看起来太累了。我说，你知道吗，尽管我们有预约，但现在已经很晚了，我确信我是你的最后一个病人，让我明天再来吧。
However, she said, no, no, I've got time. Suzanne had to make a decision. She was worried the pharmacist was fatigued. Was it wise to proceed? Could something go wrong? My intuition was step away. She wasn't in a good place to give me the shot. But I wanted to be a pleaser
然而，她说，不，不，我有时间。苏珊必须做出决定。她担心药剂师很疲惫。继续进行明智吗？会出什么问题吗？我的直觉是离开。她当时的状态不适合给我打针。但我想要做一个讨好别人的人，
and not contradict her ability to help me out at that time with our appointment. You've probably had moments like this. A voice of doubt creeps into your mind. and you have a quandary, should you listen to your doubts or push them aside in favor of certainty? Suzanne decided to ignore her doubts. She agreed to stay, to get the flu shot. And I said, do you want me to sit? And she said, no, I can just stand above you. I was going to face a certain direction. And she placed the needle into my rotator cuff, which left me screaming. And she said, relax, relax, I feel like I'm, I feel like I'm,
而不是反驳她当时通过我们的预约来帮忙的能力。你可能也经历过这样的时刻。一丝怀疑的声音潜入你的脑海，让你陷入两难境地：你应该听从心中的疑虑，还是将其抛在一边去追求确定性？苏珊决定忽视心中的疑虑。她同意留下来，接种流感疫苗。我说，你想让我坐下吗？她说，不，我可以站在你上方。我本来要面向某个方向。她把针扎进了我的肩袖，这让我尖叫起来。她说，放松，放松，我觉得我，我觉得我，
going to break the needle off. Well, she completely tore my rotator cuff, which has been a problem that's plagued me since the pandemic. And I've done all sorts of medical interventions, but it was a very bad situation that has led me to difficulty. We're often told, don't be a doubting Thomas. Plunge in, full speed ahead. But there are times when taking a pause and listening to our doubts
要把针折断了。嗯，她完全撕裂了我的肩袖，这成了困扰我直到大流行结束的一个问题。我做过各种各样的医疗干预，但那是一个非常糟糕的情况，给我带来了痛苦。我们经常被告知，不要做一个多疑的托马斯。全力以赴，一往直前。但有时，停下来听听我们心中的疑虑，
can help us make better decisions. How can we identify the moments when doubt is our friend? That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Whether at work or in politics, we tend to prefer people who are decisive,
可以帮助我们做出更好的决定。我们如何识别怀疑是我们的朋友的时刻？休息一下，我们马上回来。您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。无论在工作中还是在政治上，我们往往更喜欢那些果断的人，
who never appear to question their own thoughts or actions. But is that always a good thing? At the University of Virginia, Bobby Parmar studies the science of the unknown. He joined us for a recent episode titled, Trusting Your Doubt. Today, he returns to the show to respond to listener questions about the science of doubt. Bobby Parmar, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me, Shanker.
他们从不表现出对自己的想法或行动的质疑。但这总是件好事吗？在弗吉尼亚大学（University of Virginia），鲍比·帕尔马（Bobby Parmar）研究未知科学。他参加了我们最近的一期节目，题为《信任你的疑虑》。今天，他重返节目，回答听众关于怀疑科学的问题。鲍比·帕尔马，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我，尚卡尔。
Bobby, we talked in our last conversation about how the human mind is hardwired to prefer certainty. We don't like the feeling of doubt. Why is it that our brains are built like this? You know, for so many of us, certainty feels so good. There's just this great feeling that we get when we can predict what's going to happen, when we've mastered our environment or the way that we think about things matches the world in which we find ourselves. And certainty requires very little cognitive effort. There's a lot of research that shows that we find cognitive effort costly and aversive. You know, it almost feels painful to exert cognitive effort. psychology is a science, unlike physics, we don't have lots of laws, but one law we do have is the law of least work, which is the idea that if there are two options and they both have the same amount of reward, most organisms are going to choose the option that requires lower effort, lower physical effort, lower cognitive effort.
鲍比，我们在上一次对话中谈到了人类大脑天生偏爱确定性。我们不喜欢怀疑的感觉。为什么我们的大脑会这样构造呢？你知道，对我们很多人来说，确定性感觉太好了。当我们能够预测将要发生的事情、当我们掌握了周围的环境，或者我们思考问题的方式与我们所处的环境相契合时，我们会有一种极好的感觉。而且确定性只需要极少的认知努力。大量研究表明，我们认为认知努力是昂贵且令人厌恶的。你知道，付出认知努力甚至让人感觉痛苦。心理学是一门科学，与物理学不同，我们没有很多定律，但我们确实有一个定律，那就是最小努力法则，这个想法是，如果有两个选项，并且它们都具有相同数量的奖励，那么大多数生物都会选择需要较低努力的选项，较低的物理努力，较低的认知努力。
You've given your students different scenarios where they have to grapple with their own doubts. One was a thought experiment involving an airline pilot and whether he should be allowed to fly a plane. Talk about the scenario and what it tells us about doubt and decision-making. One of the ways in which we train our students to make better decisions under conditions of uncertainty is to give them practice in lots of different types of examples. And so this is an example that we've used in the past as an exam case or as a classroom discussion where there's a pilot for an airline. And through his own routine testing in his personal life, he's a discovers that he has the gene for hunting this disease.
你曾给学生们提供不同的场景，让他们与自己的疑虑做斗争。其中一个是关于一名飞机机长以及他是否应该被允许驾驶飞机的思想实验。谈谈这个场景，以及它告诉了我们关于怀疑和决策的什么信息。我们训练学生在不确定性条件下做出更好决策的方法之一，就是让他们在许多不同类型的例子中进行练习。所以这是一个我们过去用作考试案例或课堂讨论的例子，其中有一个航空公司的机长。通过他个人生活中的例行检测，他发现自己携带了亨廷顿舞蹈症的基因。
And this is a disease that basically causes the neurons between the brain and the muscles to atrophy. And so sometimes patients can lose control over their bodily movement. Sometimes it can happen very gradually. Other times it can happen very suddenly. And the pilot discloses this information on social media and then takes it down. But you, as let's say a leader in this airline, learn about this. and now you have to figure out what to do. Do you allow this person to continue to fly?
这是一种基本上会导致大脑和肌肉之间的神经元萎缩的疾病。因此，有时患者会失去对自己身体运动的控制。有时这种情况发生得很慢。其他时候它会非常突然地发生。机长在社交媒体上披露了这一信息，随后又将其删除。但是，作为这家航空公司的领导者，你了解到了这一点，现在你必须弄清楚该怎么做。你还允许这个人继续飞行吗？
Do you take them out of the cockpit? Do you put in, you know, safety protocols? How do you handle a situation like this? And I'm assuming it's a little tricky because health information is confidential information, is it not? Absolutely. And particularly information around someone's genetics. We have laws that prevent the use of that in a work setting.
你把他从驾驶舱里撤下来吗？你引入了什么安全协议吗？你如何处理这样 A 的情况？我假设这有点棘手，因为健康信息是机密信息，对吗？绝对是的。尤其是关于某人基因的信息。我们有法律禁止在工作环境中使用这些信息。
But one loophole in the law is if someone discloses that information on social media. So companies are allowed to use that information if you voluntarily disclose that information. And so now you're in a position where legally you can use this information because this person has disclosed on social media. But morally, you're not sure if this is the right thing to do for the pilot, for your company, for passengers. And it's a really tricky scenario because we can interpret it in multiple ways.
但法律上的一个漏洞是，如果有人在社交媒体上披露了这些信息。因此，如果你自愿披露这些信息，公司就可以使用这些信息。所以现在你处于这样一种境地：从法律上讲，你可以使用这些信息，因为这个人已经在社交媒体上披露了。但在道德上，你并不确定这样做对机长、对你的公司、对乘客来说是否是正确的事情。这是一个非常棘手的场景，因为我们可以用多种方式来解读它。
What is our primary responsibility or obligation here? Is it to protect our passengers? what do we owe this pilot, privacy, transparency, care. And students really struggle with the uncertainty and the doubt in this kind of scenario. I understand that some students reach for a very quick conclusion while others are willing to sit with a doubt and uncertainty a little longer. Yeah, and you can really see it in the way that they respond to the scenario. So some students will very quickly say, look, I don't think we should have this information.
我们这里的主要责任或义务是什么？是保护我们的乘客吗？我们欠这位机长什么，隐私、透明度、关怀。在这个场景中，学生们真的在不确定性和疑虑中挣扎。我听说有些学生很快就得出了结论，而另一些人则愿意多花一点时间去面对疑虑和不确定性。是的，你确实可以在他们对场景的反应中看到这一点。因此，有些学生会很快地说，看，我认为我们不应该掌握这些信息。
I feel bad about the situation. I'm going to allow him to fly, and I'm not going to pay attention to the fact that I learned this information. It's a very quick, intuitive reaction that they then justify by picking a couple of pieces of information that are aligned with their gut feeling. Other students are able to examine the situation from multiple perspectives, thinking about perhaps what policy should the airline have regarding genetic testing in the future, thinking about what does it mean to protect this particular pilot? and his interests and his, you know, goals for his career. And what they're able to do is to generate a set of solutions that are sensitive to all of those different aspects of the scenario. They've, I don't like to use the phrase sitting with doubt or sitting with uncertainty because
我对这种情况感到难过。我要让他飞行，而且我不会去注意我了解到了这个信息。这是一个非常快速的直觉反应，然后他们通过挑选几个符合他们直觉的信息来证明这一点。其他学生能够从多个角度审视这种情况，思考航空公司未来可能应该对基因检测制定什么政策，思考保护这位特定机长意味着什么，以及他的利益和他的职业目标。他们能够做出一系列对场景的所有这些不同方面都敏感的解决方案。他们，我不太喜欢用“与疑虑共处”或“与不确定性共处”这样的短语，因为
they're actually playing with it. They're active. And they're using that doubt to learn about what's possible to do. And so their recommendations are much more robust. They're much more well thought out. They have plans in place to consult with doctors and to report things to the FAA under certain conditions. They're partnering with the pilot in question to put in safety protocols to protect his privacy so other people don't learn about his condition, to make sure there are safety protocols for passengers so their risk isn't increased in any way, shape, or form. And this kind of effective problem solving can only really happen when decision makers are comfortable with not knowing.
他们实际上是在与之互动。他们是积极的。他们利用这种疑虑来了解可能做的事情。因此他们的建议要稳健得多。他们考虑得更周全。他们有计划在特定条件下咨询医生并向联邦航空管理局（FAA）报告。他们与相关机长合作制定安全协议以保护他的隐私，这样其他人就不会了解他的病情，以确保乘客的安全协议，从而以任何形状或形式都不会增加他们的风险。只有当决策者对未知感到安稳时，这种有效的解决问题的方式才能真正发生。
Hmm. One of the things that I find interesting about doubt is that there is something of a Goldilocks dimension to this emotion. The right amount of doubt can help us to look around corners, address problems before they emerge, but too much doubt can become paralyzing. We received a question about this from a listener named Chevenise, who says she struggles with too much doubt. My doubt has shifted from something that's occasional to something that's frequent. and I have a mind of my own and should be taken full responsibility of my decisions, whether acting independently or choosing to go along with others. But I often second-guess my judgment. As a result, I started defaulting to let others make decisions,
嗯。关于怀疑，我发现有趣的一件事是，这种情绪具有某种“金发姑娘”维度。适度的怀疑可以帮助我们未雨绸缪，在问题出现之前解决问题，但过多的怀疑会让人瘫痪。一位名叫舍维尼斯（Chevenise）的听众向我们提出了一个关于此的问题，她说她一直在与过多的怀疑作斗争。我的怀疑已经从偶尔发生的事情变成了经常发生的事情。我是一个有独立思想的人，应该对自己的决定承担全部责任，无论是独立行动还是选择随大流。但我经常对自己的判断产生二次猜测。结果，我开始默认让别人来做决定，
not because I don't know, but because if I'm wrong, I feel safer when the potential shame belongs to someone else rather than myself. So how do I move past that? Bobby, do you have any practical advice for people like Shevin D? who doubt themselves too much? Such an important question and one that so many of us struggle with, whether it's doubting too much like Chauvinese pointed to or not doubting enough and running headfirst into a set of solutions or alternatives.
不是因为我不知道，而是因为如果我错了，当潜在的耻辱属于别人而不是我自己时，我会觉得更安全。那么我该如何克服这一点呢？鲍比，对于像舍维尼斯这样对自己怀疑太多的人，你有什么实际的建议吗？这是一个非常重要的问题，也是我们许多人都在挣扎的问题，无论是像舍维尼斯所指出的那样怀疑过多，还是怀疑不足并一头扎进一套解决方案或替代方案中。
You know, one thing that is helpful in identifying that Goldiloxone is something that I call the principle of requisite variety. And the idea is that it takes complexity to notice complexity. Take, for example, your immune system. If your body only had antibodies for, let's say, two types of cold or two types of virus, then you'd get sick all the time if your environment had lots of different types of viruses in it. But if your immune system could represent all of those different types of viruses and had antibodies for all those different types of viruses,
你知道，有助于识别那个“金发姑娘区间”的一件事是我称之为“必要多样性原则”的东西。这个想法是，需要复杂性才能注意到复杂性。以你的免疫系统为例。如果你的身体只有针对，比如说，两种感冒或两种病毒的抗体，那么如果你的环境中有很多不同类型的病毒，你就会经常生病。但如果你的免疫系统能够代表所有这些不同类型的病毒，并且拥有所有这些不同类型的病毒的抗体，
you could deal with the complexity of the situation that you find yourself in. And so, ideally, if we bring this back to thinking and making decisions, the way that we think about things has to match the complexity of the situations that we find ourselves in. And so we can make two types of error. We can make the error where our thinking is too simple for a world that's more complicated,
你就能应对你所处环境的复杂性。因此，理想情况下，如果我们把这一点带回到思考和决策上来，我们思考问题的方式必须与我们所处环境的复杂性相匹配。所以我们可以犯两种错误。我们可以犯这样的错误：我们的思维对于一个更复杂的世界来说过于简单了，
or we could make the error that Chavonese has pointed out to, which is that our thinking can be way too complicated for a situation that we're facing. And so there's a couple of things that I think are helpful in this regard. The first is to remember that the point of engaging, in doubt is to act better, not to get the right answer. And so sometimes we ruminate and we go back and say, look, I want to make sure I get the perfect answer here. And that's why I'm thinking over
或者我们可能会犯舍维尼斯所指出的错误，那就是我们的思维对于我们所面对的情况来说可能过于复杂了。因此，我认为在这方面有几件有帮助的事情。首先是要记住，参与怀疑的目的是为了做得更好，而不是为了得到正确的答案。所以有时我们会反思并回头说：看，我想确保在这里得到完美的答案。这就是为什么我在思考
and over again about what's happening. And a better way of assessing your thinking is to say, did this help me run a experiment that was worthwhile? Did this help me take the next step in a way that I feel proud of and confident in? And so one of the things we want to ask ourselves is, do I feel like I know enough that I can act? And can I act in a way, that maybe isn't an all-or-nothing decision, but it's a next step that allows me to learn more, gain more confidence, and iterate from there. Shevonese's struggle to control her feelings of doubt
一遍又一遍地思考发生了什么。评估你思维的一种更好的方法是说：这是否有助于我进行一次值得进行的实验？这是否有助于我以一种我感到自豪和自信的方式迈出下一步？因此，我们要问自己的事情之一是：我觉得我知道得足以采取行动吗？我能否以这样一种方式采取行动：也许这不是一个非黑即白的决定，而是一个下一步，它允许我了解更多，获得更多信心，并在此基础上进行迭代？舍维尼斯难以控制自己的怀疑情绪，
feel really relatable and common. Interestingly, it also gets a deeper question about free will that are currently raging in the academic world. You say that doubt can be a bellwether in the debate over free will? I think that's exactly right. Currently, the debate is framed as a binary. Either we have free will and we can make choices that are divorced from our context and our biology and our history, or we don't have free will and all of our choices are determined by our context, our genetics, our history.
让人感觉真的很感同身受且普遍。有趣的是，它也引发了学术界目前正在激烈争论的关于自由意志的更深层次的问题。你说怀疑可以成为自由意志辩论中的风向标？我认为完全正确。目前，辩论被框定为一个二元对立。要么我们拥有自由意志，我们可以做出脱离我们的环境、我们的生物学和我们的历史的选择；要么我们没有自由意志，我们的所有选择都由我们的环境、我们的遗传学、我们的历史决定。
And I think doubt provides a really interesting lens on that particular debate. When we experience certainty, we don't think that there are other options. It's kind of like certainty constrains our thinking, and we have these conditioned, quick responses to the situations that we're facing. Doubt kind of disrupts those subconscious or unconscious scripts that we have and provides a pause between stimulus and response. And in that pause, we can think of other ways of interpreting what's happening around us. And now that we can choose between alternate interpretations, is this person giving me this difficult feedback because they want to hurt me or because they care about me. I don't know. But now by choosing between those different interpretations, I'm opening up some degrees of freedom. It's still not completely
我认为怀疑为这场特定的辩论提供了一个非常有趣的视角。当我们体验到确定性时，我们不认为还有其他选择。这有点像确定性限制了我们的思维，我们对所面临的情况有这些条件反射式的、快速的反应。怀疑某种程度上打破了我们拥有的那些潜意识或无意识的脚本，并在刺激和反应之间提供了一个暂停。在这个暂停中，我们可以思考围绕我们发生的事情的其他解释方式。现在我们可以选择不同的解释，这个人给我这个困难的反馈是因为他们想伤害我，还是因为他们关心我？我不知道。但现在通过在这些不同的解释之间进行选择，我开启了一些自由度。它仍然不完全
divorced from history and context and biology, but it is a degree of freedom where I get to shape and author my life in ways that I couldn't if I didn't see alternative choices. I mean, in this model, exercising free will is almost a skill. It's not something we have or don't have. it's something that we can choose to have. That's exactly right, because when we take the time to learn about what's happening around us and not default to whatever dominant interpretation is in our environment or the first thing that occurs to our mind, then we're building the capacity to exercise our free will
脱离历史、环境和生物学，但它是一个自由度，在这个自由度中，我可以以如果没有看到替代选择就无法做到的方式塑造和撰写我的生活。我的意思是，在这个模型中，行使自由意志几乎是一项技能。这不是我们拥有或不拥有的东西。这是我们可以选择拥有的东西。完全正确，因为当我们花时间去了解我们周围发生的事情，而不默认我们环境中的任何主导解释或浮现在我们脑海中的第一件事时，我们就正在培养行使自由意志的能力
by changing the way that we interpret the world around us. We've all heard the phrase, trust your gut. We typically interpret that to mean that we should act decisively. listener Michelle has a question about that. How do you reconcile radical doubt with the idea of embodiment, particularly the role of gut feelings or bodily signals in decision-making? Many of us are encouraged, especially in modern talk therapy, to listen to our bodies or notice somatic cues as sources of insight.
通过改变我们解释周围世界的方式。我们都听说过“相信你的直觉”这句话。我们通常将其理解为我们应该果断行事。听众米歇尔（Michelle）对此有一个问题。你如何将彻底的怀疑与具身化的概念相调和，特别是直觉或身体信号在决策中的作用？我们许多人被鼓励，特别是在现代谈话疗法中，去倾听我们的身体或注意到作为洞察力来源的躯体线索。
But as Bobby discusses, those signals can also be shaped by fear, bias, or past experience. So how do you practice embodiment while still exploring your doubt? So Bobby, we hear a lot about paying attention to bodily cues like your heart rate or butterflies in your stomach. Sometimes these signals can be helpful in alerting us to danger, but sometimes they can also be debilitating in keeping us from performing at our best. I think Michelle's question is insightful. Are these physical cues, the manifestations of doubt? I love this question. I think it's such an important one. And Michelle is exactly right.
但正如鲍比所讨论的，这些信号也可能受到恐惧、偏见或过去经验的影响。那么，你如何在探索怀疑的同时练习具身化呢？所以鲍比，我们经常听到要关注身体线索，比如你的心率或胃里的蝴蝶效应。有时这些信号有助于提醒我们注意危险，但有时它们也可能使人衰弱，使我们无法发挥出最佳水平。我认为米歇尔的问题很有洞察力。这些身体线索是怀疑的表现吗？我喜欢这个问题。我认为这是一个非常重要的问题。米歇尔完全正确。
We're always told to pay attention to our gut, and the body knows what the right answer is. And if we take that seriously, the body is giving us really important signals. Those somatic cues, whether that's sweaty palms or butterflies in your stomach or feeling your jaw tightened because you think this is a situation that is making you angry.
我们总是被告知要注意我们的直觉，身体知道正确的答案是什么。如果我们认真对待这一点，身体正在给我们非常重要的信号。这些躯体线索，无论是手心出汗、胃里翻江倒海，还是感觉到你的下巴变紧，因为你认为这是一个让你生气的局面。
Those are really important signals, but we might not treat them as commands, right? We might not treat them as the final interpretation of the situation that we're facing. We want to treat them as important information that is teaching us something about our own history. Why is it that we're having this set of somatic reactions? Maybe something happened to us in the past
这些是非常重要的信号，但我们可能不把它们当作命令，对吧？我们可能不把它们当作我们所面对局面的最终解释。我们希望把它们当作重要的信息，向我们传授一些关于我们自身历史的东西。为什么我们会有一套这样的躯体反应？也许过去发生在我们身上的事
and our body's trying to warn us. That warning may be very wise, it may be unwise in the specific situation we're facing. And so treating those somatic cues as another hypothesis to say, huh, my body's telling me I should get out of here. What else in this environment is consistent with that hypothesis? And also, what else is inconsistent with that hypothesis? It is very important to take the time to retrain your body.
我们的身体正试图警告我们。这种警告可能非常明智，在特定的情况下也可能不明智。因此，将这些躯体线索视为另一个假设，说：嗯，我的身体在告诉我，我应该离开这里。这个环境中的什么其他东西与这个假设一致？还有，什么与这个假设不一致？花时间重新训练你的身体是非常重要的。
And so when we look at all different types of therapy, particularly exposure therapy. So, you know, in my past, I have this vivid memory of taking my daughter to a discovery museum, you know, she was three years old and going down these giant slides and dad come with me and I'm going down the slide and it's like a completely covered slide like a tube. And halfway through, I am having a panic attack. I am stuck in this slide. I'm an adult. I don't know if I'm going to get out. And, you know, my body is telling me I got to go. I'm in danger. Now, once I got out of the slide, of course, you're not in any real mortal danger, right? And you're, you'd know that that wasn't the right interpretation.
因此，当我们查看所有不同类型的疗法，特别是暴露疗法时。所以，你知道，在我的过去，我有一个生动的记忆，带我女儿去探索博物馆，你知道，她当时三岁，从这些巨大的滑梯滑下来，爸爸跟我来，我正滑下滑梯，它就像一个完全覆盖的滑梯，像一个管子。滑到一半，我正在经历恐慌发作。我被困在这个滑梯里。我是一个成年人。我不知道我能不能出去。而且，你知道，我的身体在告诉我，我得走了。我有危险。现在，一旦我滑出了滑梯，当然，你没有任何真正的致命危险，对吧？而且你会，你知道那不是正确的解释。
It was important for me over time to train my body to not have that reaction. And it doesn't happen just by thinking different thoughts. You have to take the time to expose your body slowly to those kinds of stimulus where perhaps your somatic reaction isn't matching the environment that you're in. A listener named Nancy sent us a note pointing out what she sees as one benefit of doubt. She says that doubt, which is often seen as a negative thing, can lead us to something that everyone would agree is positive and that thing is curiosity. What do you think, Bobby? I 100% agree with Nancy.
随着时间的推移，对我来说，训练我的身体不要有那种反应是很重要的。这不仅仅是通过思考不同的想法就能发生的。你必须花时间让你的身体慢慢暴露在那些刺激中，也许你的躯体反应与你所处的环境不匹配。一位名叫南希（Nancy）的听众给我们发来便条，指出了她所看到的怀疑的一个好处。她说，通常被视为消极事物的怀疑，可以引导我们走向每个人都会同意是积极的事物，而那个事物就是好奇心。你怎么看，鲍比？我百分之百同意南希的看法。
There are conditions under which when we see the benefits of engaging in that cognitive effort, of learning, of noticing differently, that we can gain the benefits of doubt by turning doubt into curiosity. There are also times where we don't see those benefits, where we're paying at more. much more attention to the costs of that cognitive effort, where doubt feels like, you know, this is something where my body's telling me, I got to get out of here. This is a situation I have to avoid. And so this balance of how much excitement or benefit we see and how much threat we see is really critical from turning doubt into this thing that is painful, into doubt that is something that is positive, and curiosity is a great way of thinking about the positive version of doubt. When we come back, how we can use doubt to motivate ourselves.
在某些情况下，当我们看到参与这种认知努力、学习、以不同方式注意力的好处时，我们可以通过将怀疑转化为好奇心来获得怀疑的好处。也有一些时候，我们看不到这些好处，我们付出了更多。更多地关注这种认知努力的成本，此时怀疑感觉就像，你知道，这是我的身体在告诉我的事情，我必须离开这里。这是一个我必须避免的情况。因此，我们看到多少兴奋或好处与我们看到多少威胁之间的平衡，对于将怀疑从这种痛苦的事情转变为积极的事情至关重要，而好奇心是思考怀疑的积极版本的好方法。当我们回来时，我们如何利用怀疑来激励自己。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At the University of Virginia, Bobby Parmar studies when to listen to the voice of doubt in your head. He's the author of Radical Doubt, Turning Uncertainty into Shorefire Success. Bobby, let's turn to the implications of your research in workplaces. We've talked about our preference for leaders who act decisively. In many corporate environments, employees who ask clarifying questions or pause to consider a decision are often perceived as hesitant or even obstacles to reaching a goal.
您收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在弗吉尼亚大学，鲍比·帕尔马研究何时倾听你脑海中的怀疑之声。他是《彻底的怀疑：将不确定性转化为确定的成功》（Radical Doubt, Turning Uncertainty into Shorefire Success）一书的作者。鲍比，让我们转向你的研究在工作场所中的影响。我们已经讨论过我们对果断行事的领导者的偏爱。在许多企业环境中，提出澄清问题或暂停考虑决定的员工通常被视为犹豫不决，甚至是实现目标的障碍。
Confident voices, on the other hand, are praised for their conviction. I'm thinking of Mark Zuckerberg's famous motto, to move fast and break things, for example. Listener, Amy had a question about doubt in the workplace. She writes, how do organizations benefit from seasoned, reflective thinking when their cultures often privilege confidence over consideration? What a powerful question from Amy. One that I spend a lot of time thinking about and working with organizations around. And she's absolutely right. There are cultures that prioritize confidence and decisiveness over uncertainty.
另一方面，自信的声音因其坚定的信念而受到赞扬。例如，我想到了马克·扎克伯格（Mark Zuckerberg）的名言：行动迅速，打破常规。听众艾米（Amy）对工作场所的怀疑提出了一个问题。她写道：当组织文化往往赋予自信高于深思熟虑时，组织如何从经验丰富、反思性的思考中受益？来自艾米的一个如此有力的问题。这是一个我花了很多时间思考并与组织合作的问题。她说得完全对。有些文化将自信和果断置于不确定性之上。
And many of those cultures over time realize that that can lead to wasted time and effort and burnout in their employees when leaders aren't taking the time to exercise some wisdom and curiosity. And so then many of those companies come around to say, well, how can we make better decisions? How can we embrace doubt more effectively in our day-to-day decision-making so that we can avoid some of these costly errors that come out of perhaps a false certainty? And there's lots of things that leaders can do, thankfully. One tactic that I like is to be very careful about how we structure meetings and conversations. If you are a senior leader leading a conversation about, let's say, a new product proposal, it's very easy to let people say whatever they want. And, you know, typically if you're in a culture where people show that they're really smart by poking holes in other people's idea within the first 10 minutes,
随着时间的推移，许多这样的文化意识到，当领导者不花时间去行使一些智慧和好奇心时，这会导致员工的时间和精力浪费以及倦怠。因此，许多这些公司回过头来想，好吧，我们怎样才能做出更好的决策？我们如何在日常决策中更有效地拥抱怀疑，以避免可能源于虚假确定性的这些代价高昂的错误？谢天谢地，领导者可以做很多事情。我喜欢的一个策略是，非常小心我们如何构建会议和对话。如果你是一位高级领导者，正在领导一场关于，比如说，新产品提案的对话，让人畅所欲言是很容易的。而且，你知道，通常如果你身处这样一种文化中，人们通过在前10分钟内挑出别人想法中的漏洞来证明自己真的很聪明，
everyone is very negative about this new product proposal. And what I've seen wise leaders do is they actually timebox those things. And they say, okay, the first thing I'd like for us to do is to spend some time thinking about the virtues of this idea. And once they've done that, then they think through, okay, what are some concerns that we have or some weaknesses that we should be aware of? And by taking time to think about both of those things, we don't become overly negative or overly positive about an idea. and we can exercise much more careful and critical thinking. I'd like to talk about the types of situations where it might feel like there isn't time to stop
每个人都对这个新产品提案非常消极。而我看到明智的领导者所做的是，他们实际上对这些事情进行了时间限制。他们说，好的，我希望我们做的第一件事是花一些时间思考这个想法的优点。一旦他们做到了这一点，他们就会思考，好吧，我们有哪些担忧或我们应该注意的弱点？通过花时间思考这两件事，我们不会对一个想法变得过于消极或过于积极，
and allow space for doubt. Listener Nancy, who made the connection between doubt and curiosity, sent us this message. She says, I can see how training and practice in the management of doubt can be quite useful in a situation where there's some time to ask questions and consider alternative points of view.
我们可以进行更谨慎和批判性的思考。我想谈谈那些可能感觉没有时间停下来并为怀疑留出空间的场景。听众南希，她将怀疑与好奇心联系在了一起，给我们发了这条消息。她说，我可以看到，在有一些时间提出问问题并考虑替代观点的情况下，管理怀疑的培训和练习会非常有用。
However, what about in sudden or emergency situation? With practice, can doubt trump more reactive thinking? What do you think, Bobby? Is doubt less useful in situations where you have to make quick decisions like an emergency? This is a question that I often get from executives, and I think Nancy has placed her finger on something that is very important to think about. I think doubt is very helpful in acute emergency situations. It's just helpful at a different stage of the process.
然而，突发或紧急情况呢？通过练习，怀疑能战胜更多的反应式思维吗？你怎么看，鲍比？在必须做出快速决定（如紧急情况）的情况下，怀疑是否没那么有用？这是高管们经常问我的一个问题，我认为南希触及了非常重要的一点。我认为怀疑在急性紧急情况下非常有用。它只是在过程的不同阶段有用。
And so often I'll work with medical professionals who are operating, in an ER or in an emergency room, folks who might work on an aircraft carrier or a nuclear power plant, and all of these situations require very quick, decisive action and decision-making. And so to Nancy's point, people don't have even a few minutes to think about what they might do. And what ends up happening is under those conditions of stress, acute time pressure or social stress, lack of resources, people fall back on their habits. And if they have strong training, those habits can help them in those situations. And if they don't have strong training or if they haven't been trained for that particular crisis, their habits can't help them or don't help them in those situations.
因此，我经常与在急诊室工作的医疗专业人员合作，或者在航空母舰或核电站工作的人员，所有这些情况都需要非常迅速、果断的行动和决策。因此，按照南希的说法，人们甚至没有几分钟的时间来考虑他们可能会做什么。结果就是，在那种压力条件下，巨大的时间压力或社会压力、缺乏资源，人们会退回到他们的习惯中。如果他们有强有力的训练，这些习惯可以在那些情况下帮助他们。如果他们没有接受过强有力的训练，或者他们没有针对该特定危机进行过训练，他们的习惯就无法帮助他们，或者在那些情况下帮不上忙。
And so what we end up seeing in those acute moments is that typically there's an error. Something happened. A patient died on the operating table. There was a containment issue in the power plant. And then once that error is contained, people come back and they use doubt to learn about what happened. Why did it happen? What could we do differently next time? And they use the insights from that learning process to retrain or train the next group of people who will be confronting that situation.
因此，我们最终在那些关键时刻看到的是，通常会出现错误。有些事情发生了。病人在手术台上死了。发电厂存在遏制问题。然后一旦该错误得到控制，人们就会回来并利用怀疑来了解发生了什么。为什么会发生？下次我们能做些什么不同的事情？他们利用从该学习过程中获得的洞察力来重新培训或培训下一批将面对这种情况的人。
And so we see those benefits of doubt occur after an error where people don't have a chance to actually think carefully. and then that learning is used to adapt the training to minimize the likelihood of the error in the future. I love this idea because, of course, the situations that come up, even in emergency settings, are often situations that we've confronted before. And this explains why, you know, when an EMT shows up at the crash site of an accident, the EMT doesn't lose their head. They're able to react calmly. They're able to think about things.
因此，我们看到怀疑的好处发生在错误之后，当时人们没有机会真正仔细思考，然后这种学习被用来调整训练，以尽量减少将来发生错误的可能性。我喜欢这个想法，因为当然，即使在紧急情况下出现的场景，也往往是我们以前遇到过的场景。这就解释了为什么，你知道，当急救医疗技术员（EMT）出现在事故现场时，急救人员不会惊慌失措。他们能够冷静地反应。他们能够思考事情。
It's because they've been in the scenario before. They've trained for it. Absolutely. And it takes time to practice and to really learn to regulate yourself and what to pay attention to. And so thank goodness they have that training. We all benefit from that. We received a number of messages from listeners who shared stories about the role of doubt in their assessments of their romantic relationships. Here's one from listener, Lauren.
这是因为他们以前经历过这个场景。他们为此进行过训练。绝对是的，练习和真正学会自我调节以及注意什么需要时间。所以谢天谢地他们有那样的训练。我们所有人都从中受益。我们收到了许多听众的信息，他们分享了关于怀疑在他们评估恋爱关系中的作用的故事。这里有一位听众劳伦（Lauren）的故事。
There's this prevalent idea that when you know, you know, like when you're with that right person, the person you're supposed to be with, you just know. And I found that in a relationship where I really thought I knew very early on and then spent four years finding out that I was wrong. And I wonder if I had had some more doubt if I would have noticed some of those patterns earlier instead of leaning back to that sense of knowing that sense of certainty. And since getting out of that relationship, it really undermined that sense of knowing and I've been flooded with doubt, which has also been problematic
有一种普遍的想法，那就是当你懂了，你就懂了，就像当你和那个对的人在一起时，你注定要在一起的人，你就是知道。我发现在一段关系中，我真的以为自己很早就知道了，然后花了四年时间才发现自己错了。我想如果我有更多的疑虑，我会更早地注意到其中一些模式，而不是退回到那种知道的感觉，那种确定性的感觉。自从走出那段关系后，它确实动摇了那种知道的感觉，我被怀疑淹没了，这也是有问题的
because even the presence of doubt seems like it's supposed to be wrong because when you know you know. But I've also found that the more that I embrace that doubt, the more I'm able to use it as something that's trying to help me, but I'm still trying to find that balance. So, Bobby, this is another example of the tricky line we walk with doubt. In the best of circumstances, doubt can help us identify. identify problems and avoid unnecessary heartache.
因为即使是怀疑的存在似乎也应该是错的，因为当你懂了你就懂了。但我也发现，我越是拥抱这种怀疑，我就越能把它当作试图帮助我的东西来使用，但我仍在努力寻找这种平衡。所以，鲍比，这是我们与怀疑走钢丝的另一个例子。在最好的情况下，怀疑可以帮助我们识别。识别问题并避免不必要的痛苦。
But on the other hand, there's a risk that it can lead us to ruminate. How do we walk this line, particularly in situations where our emotions are deeply invested in the outcome, such as our romantic relationships? This is such a great example of how we're all taught to be right answer getters. You know, when you know, you know, it's certain. You know, it's a match made in heaven. It's a perfect puzzle piece. How can there be doubt?
但另一方面，它可能会导致我们反思的风险。我们如何走好这条钢丝，特别是在我们的情感对结果投入很深的情况下，比如我们的恋爱关系？这是一个很好的例子，说明我们所有人都被教导要成为正确答案的获取者。你知道，当你懂了，你就懂了，那是确定的。你知道，那是天作之合。这是一个完美的拼图。怎么会有怀疑呢？
And in fact, if there is doubt, maybe it's a, not the right relationship or the right person for you. That's the story that we're all sold. And for many of my students who are in kind of the age range where they're starting lifelong relationships and finding romantic partners, we talk about this distinction between finding and making. And when we think we're going to find the right partner,
事实上，如果存在怀疑，也许它不是适合你的关系或对的人。这就是我们都被兜售的故事。对于我的许多处于开始终身伴侣关系和寻找浪漫伴侣年龄段的学生来说，我们讨论了“寻找”和“制造”之间的区别。当我们认为我们会找到合适的伴侣时，
reinforces this idea that there's a right answer out there versus this idea of how do I make a better relationship? And making a better relationship is one, where you have to pay attention to what's working, what's not working, what do we have in common, what do we not have in common, how do we like to live together, how are we going to solve conflicts and problems? And you're less focused on getting the right answer and avoiding doubt and more focused on saying, what am I learning about myself and my partner and what it will take for us to build a life together, to build a relationship together. And when Lauren talked about
这强化了这样一种想法：外面有一个正确的答案，而不是“我如何建立更好的关系”这个想法。而建立更好的关系是这样一种关系：你必须注意什么在起作用，什么不起作用，我们有什么共同点，我们没有什么共同点，我们如何喜欢生活在一起，我们将如何解决冲突和问题。你不再那么关注获得正确答案和避免怀疑，而是更多地关注：我正在了解关于我自己和我的伙伴以及我们需要什么来共同建立生活，共同建立关系。当劳伦谈到
using her doubt, you know, more productively, I would imagine that that's the kind of work that she's doing. It's worth noting that it can be particularly difficult to listen to our doubt when we're going against the norms and perceived wisdom of the people around us. This can be true in the workplace, but it can also be true in other contexts as well. Listener Hillary says she struggled with this tension when it comes to raising her children. I never know if I am doing the right thing when my belief differs from that of the majority, I often wonder, am I missing something and how to hold firm to the possibility
更富有成效地利用她的怀疑时，我猜这就是她正在做的那种工作。值得注意的是，当我们违背周围人的规范和感知智慧时，倾听我们的怀疑可能会特别困难。这在工作场所可能是真的，但在其他情况下也可能是真的。听众希拉里（Hillary）说，她在养育孩子方面对这种紧张关系进行了斗争。当我的信仰与大多数人不同时，我永远不知道自己是否在做正确的事情，我经常想，我错过了什么，以及如何坚守这种可能性：
that it's okay, that I don't think the same way? So researchers like Bob Chaldeenie have shown how easily we're influenced by what is popular in our social circles, Bobby. Hillary here is talking about this in the context of parenting, but I think we've all experienced this feeling that everyone is doing something one way. Surely that must be the right way to do it. I can empathize with Hillary's story so much. You know, when we were raising our daughters, we had a very similar moment.
没关系，我不这么想？因此，像鲍勃·查尔迪尼（Bob Chaldeenie）这样的研究人员已经展示了我们是多么容易受到社交圈中流行事物的影响，鲍比。希拉里在这里是在育儿的背景下谈论这个的，但我认为我们都经历过这种感觉：每个人都在以某种方式做一件事。那肯定是一条正确的方法。我对希拉里的故事深有同感。你知道，当我们养育女儿时，我们有过非常相似的时刻。
My oldest daughter, who's now 18, when she was a baby, had a really hard time sleeping on her own. And everyone was saying that you should sleep train your baby. And we tried. It didn't work for her. It didn't work for us. She was crying. We were crying. and what do you do in those environments where everyone's like, this is the right answer.
我的大女儿现在18岁了，当她还是个婴儿时，很难自己入睡。每个人都说你应该对你的婴儿进行睡眠训练。我们试过了。对她不管用。对我们也不管用。她在哭。我们在哭。在每个人都说：这是正确答案的环境中，你该怎么办？
You obviously have to sleep train your baby, and it wasn't working for us. So I have a lot of empathy for what Hillary's saying. And in those moments, I think you have to step back and say, just like our intuition, just like our somatic signals, what's happening in our social environment is one hypothesis about how to deal with the situation at hand. What are other hypotheses? and what is the evidence that this alternate hypothesis, not sleep training my child or doing this thing that is different than the social norms,
你显然必须对你的婴儿进行睡眠训练，但这对我们不管用。所以我对希拉里所说的话感同身受。在那些时刻，我认为你必须退后一步说：就像我们的直觉一样，就像我们的躯体信号一样，我们的社会环境中发生的事情是关于如何处理手头情况的一个假设。还有哪些其他假设？
that that would work or that would be effective in the situation. And then there's a second piece here, which is it's not necessarily that your alternate hypothesis is the perfect right answer. It's also going to have weaknesses. And it's also going to have things that you're going to have to mitigate. And so being able to think through if I don't sleep, train my child. and my child does sleep in a bassinet next to us or in the bed, how am I going to change that over time?
这个替代假设（不训练我的孩子睡觉或做与社会规范不同的事情）的证据是什么，那会起作用或在那种情况下有效。这里还有第二个部分，也就是说，你的替代假设不一定是完美的正确答案。它也会有弱点。它也会有你必须减轻的事情。因此，能够思考如果我不训练我的孩子睡觉，我的孩子确实睡在我们旁边的小篮子里或床上，我将如何随着时间的推移改变这一点。
What are the risks of that and how can I mitigate those risks? So it still requires this process of learning and testing and iteration. One of the things that I see a lot is in society, we try to sell this idea that there's a perfect signal, that you're going to get the right answer. The perfect signal comes from society, the perfect signal comes from your body, the perfect signal comes from your gut reaction or your intuition,
这样做有什么风险，我又该如何降低这些风险？因此，这仍然需要一个学习、测试和迭代的过程。我经常看到的一种现象是，社会试图向我们兜售这样一种观念：存在一个完美的信号，能让你得到正确的答案。完美的信号来自社会，完美的信号来自你的身体，完美的信号来自你的直觉或本能，
or the textbook. And that might be true for a certain class of problems. But when we confront moments of doubt, by definition, there are multiple competing good answers, and we have to learn to use that doubt to propel more careful noticing and learning so that we can make something work in the situation that we face. In our previous conversation, Bobby,
或是教科书。对于某类问题，这可能是对的。但当我们面对怀疑的时刻，按定义来说，会有多个相互竞争的好答案，我们必须学会利用这种怀疑来推动更仔细的观察和学习，以便让我们面对的情况有所成效。在我们之前的对话中，博比，
we discussed how to harness doubt in a positive way, a listener named Andrew shared his story along those lines. In May of last year, I was elected to a municipal position on my local city council. And in the run-up to that, I found that I was able to harness doubt, which had been a overall negative in my life. lifetime up to that point, I found myself often almost paralyzed by doubt in assessing situations in understanding my capabilities. However, in this particular exercise in the run-up to the election, what was very interesting to me through that entire process is that I was taking the
我们讨论了如何以积极的方式利用怀疑，一位名叫安德鲁的听众分享了与此相关的经历。去年五月，我当选为当地市议会的市政官员。在竞选筹备期间，我发现自己能够利用怀疑，而在此之前，怀疑在我的一生中总体上是一个负面因素。我发现自己在评估情况、理解自身能力时，经常几乎被怀疑所瘫痪。然而，在这次特殊的选举筹备实践中，在整个过程中让我觉得非常有趣的是，我花
time to review the doubts that I had and strategize that. on how to overcome those doubts. I wrote in my journal afterwards the fact that I had become friends with my doubt, and I had previously looked at doubt as my enemy. And fortunately for me, in that particular instance, win the race. I would have been happy had I not won the race
时间审视自己产生的怀疑，并制定策略来克服这些怀疑。我后来在日记中写道，我已经和我的怀疑成了朋友，而我以前一直把怀疑当作敌人。幸运的是，在那个特定的例子中，我赢得了竞选。即使我没有赢得竞选，我也会感到高兴，
simply with the growth of learning how to manage doubt. So Bobby, I love this idea of becoming friends with doubt. You know, when I sit down with my friends, I don't always have to agree with them. But being a good friend means I do have to listen to them to be open to what they're telling me. And in many ways, this captures so well what we've been talking about here. We want to listen to what doubt is telling us. But that doesn't mean we always have to follow our doubts. What an inspirational story from Andrew.
仅仅是因为学会了如何管理怀疑这种成长。所以，博比，我非常喜欢“与怀疑做朋友”这个想法。你知道，当我跟朋友坐在一起时，并不总是需要同意他们的观点。但做一个好朋友意味着我必须倾听他们的心声，对他们告诉我的一切保持开放。在许多方面，这很好地概括了我们一直在讨论的内容。我们希望倾听怀疑在向我们传达什么。但这并不意味着我们必须盲目听从怀疑。安德鲁的故事多么鼓舞人心啊。
I love this story, you know, and the metaphor of becoming friends with your doubt is such a nice metaphor. Nice connection back to Nancy's question around curiosity and being able to listen to your doubt and be informed by it without being ruled by it is such a critical skill. And it's one that I practice and I hope to inspire others to practice that in moments where we don't know how to move forward, you've got to take the time to notice things, to frame problems, generate potential alternatives or options, test them. And all of those things require a patience and a curiosity. that doesn't happen when we feel this push towards getting the right answer and getting it right away.
我非常喜欢这个故事，你知道的，把怀疑比作朋友的隐喻真是太美妙了。这很好地呼应了南希关于好奇心的提问，即能够倾听你的怀疑并从中获得启发，而不是被它所支配，这是一项至关重要的技能。这也是我一直在实践的技能，我希望激励其他人也能在不知该如何前进的时刻去实践它：你必须花时间去观察事物，去界定问题，产生潜在的替代方案或选项，然后去测试它们。所有这些都需要耐心和好奇心，而当我们感受到那种急于求成、立刻就要得到正确答案的压力时，这一切是不会发生的。
Bobby Parmar is the author of Radical Doubt, Turning Uncertainty into Surefire Success. Bobby, thank you so much for joining me again today on Hidden Brain. My pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains Executive Editor.
博比·帕马尔是《彻底的怀疑：将不确定性转化为万无一失的成功》一书的作者。博比，非常感谢你今天再次做客《隐藏的大脑》。我的荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·克雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。
If you enjoyed today's conversation, please share it with a few friends, family members, or co-workers. I do not doubt that they would get a lot out of it. I'm Shankar Vedantham. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢今天的对话，请把它分享给几位朋友、家人或同事。我毫不怀疑他们会从中受益匪浅。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。